du champion chest tour la la finale et
Fabien ça va être un petit peu toi le le
chef d'orchestre aujourd'hui puisque
c'est toi qui qui a quelque part suivi
jusqu'à maintenant les matchs ouais
suivi comme j'ai pu mais c'est vrai que
hier j'avais pu commenter le match entre
Maxime et cararwana et sueli de Alireza
contre Abdou satoraf donc j'ai cru
comprendre un petit peu comment comment
ça fonctionnait
euh donc en gros he le principe c'est
qu'ils font un tournoi tout ronde donc
il y a h joueurs qualifiés ils vont tous
s'affronter et ils font des des matchs
aller retour donc une fois avec les
blanc une fois avec les pièces noires
sil un vainqueur àud de matchs ben il a
gagné le match voilà s'il an nul et ben
il faut une partie de départage en
Armageddon
euh et donc TS avec le même principe
avec ses enchères et cetera et donc la
cadence de jeu est est rapide enfin
c'est du
15 plus je sais pas quelque chose 10
peut-être ouais ou deux ou bonf tu
oublié passage tuas oublé au passage
quand même lâché beaucoup d'infos
importantesb alors je vois que les
joueurs jouent mais les les les parties
n'arrivent pas pour le pour le moment
donc ça c'est un peu les les alléas du
du direct mesdames et messieurs je vais
ouvrir aussi le le chat les aléas du
direct les coups sont joués on voit par
les les deux joueurs on peut quand même
commenter Fabien sur les movvement de de
main on voit un petit rock de de Maxime
ici qui qui vient de partir
ouaisouis B écoute je sais pas trop quoi
bah oui mais tu peux quand même dire qu'
ouais il y a un petit rock il ait petit
il a eu petit rock à un moment donné de
pièces en même temps et l'a pas vu ouais
ouais possible aussi on sa pas ouais ça
y est les coups qui qui arrivent alors
avec un petit décalage on est on est on
est désolé mais c'est pas grave c'est
les les aléas du du direct Fab avec on
va voir un petit rock qui va partir à
mon avis côté Maxime d'ici peu voilà on
voit on voit les deux joueurs qui jouent
à fond ouais donc ben c'est une
greenfeld et donc je sais pas exactement
ce que so va jouer c'est une avec petit
rock j'ai envie de de te dire on voit
dans l'avenir on le voit dans l'avenir
vous allez le voir arriver sous vos vos
yeux et Baill alors je vais je vais
ouvrir le chat hein Fabien en attendant
le le petit rock le petit rock le petit
rock peut-être dès le prochain coup là
c'est possible qui pourrait arriver
Fabien C5 d'abord cavali 2 peut-être
peut-être le petit rock allez petit rock
hop
là petit RCK naturel oui oui naturel
naturel naturel naturel
oui donc moi j'aime bien cette vue quand
même où on voit bien les les deux
joueurs hein Fabien les caméras on voit
Maxime on voit les les Pumas les Pumas
ouais qui saute qui bondit et qui qui
flie
ouais qui qui flie à
fond euh fou G4 OK et quoi il a fait F3
fou
D7 euh mais du coup oui en fait l'image
elle est un petit peu en avance par
rapport à ok ce qu'on voit sur les
chiqut ouais ce sera un petit peu un
petit peu décalé mais c'est pas très
grave non plus ce sont les all a du du
direct Fabien h mais on a vu les les
petits rocks he
partir joueurs qui sont en réflexion
tourb1 qui vient d'être joué he par
Wesley on le voit sur les
chiquers et donc ouais donc Maxime qui
qui a joué la grenfeld qui av déjà joué
la grenfeld d' hier contre Fabiano
plutôt que son Gabin accepté euh alors
je sais pas pourquoi il décide
finalement de d'employer cette ouverture
là plutôt que l'autre euh toujours
est-il que euh bon c'est c'est c'est son
ouverture fétiche depuis longtemps et
donc là on a une position standard de
cette ouverture où donc les Blancs ont
un très beau centre mais les Noirs vont
essayer de mettre une pression dessus
donc on a vu le pion C5 venir un peu
taper sur le centre pour faire briller
le le fou G7 et sinon voilà il a il a
fait son développement donc là il y a il
y a le pion B7 attaqué donc est-ce qu'il
va nous ne pas le défendre
ou ou faire B6 ou dame C7 il a choisi de
de faire tour C8 alors pour mettre une
pression vis-à-vis du fou C4 et aussi il
faut dire que sur tour prend il sû qui à
5 qui arrivera à faire une petite
fourchettasse ouais c'est bien joué de
la part de Maxime peut-être qu'il
connaît encore hein il connaît tout il
connaît tout bien évidemment alors
attends on peut on peut peut-être
essayer de voir un on on a un genre
de de caméra on voit voilà les joueurs
en en grand ah
voilà on voit qu'il y a eu un
déplacement de de Wesley et petite
question est-ce qu'on a un classement du
Tom juste voir
voira après
ouais par que par Wesley je sais qu'il
avait battu ikarou hier mais je sais pas
ce qu'il a fait d'autre voilà tu as le
classement ok donc Wesley 2 sur de
Magnus 2 sur
de sur de ou c'est juste des points
ouais non c'est sur de ok fa 2 et et du
coup quand tu tu perd un match même
àarmageddon c'est comme si tu l'avais
perdu normal quoi ok donc donc ok Maxime
qui bah qui affronte un des hommes en
fort et euh et ouais on a trois joueurs
qui ferment la marche qui ont tout perdu
ikarou un peu
surprenant intéressant intéressant on
verra s'il réagit
aujourd'hui alors attends on va
essayer un truc pour essayer de de de
d'avoir d'avoir les parties plus plus en
direct on va voir ce qu'il en est
Fab tu peux avir peut-être un
lien un
lien voilà ouais donc on est plus en
direct plus en direct on est plus en
direct
là la position colle mieux aux images
exactement
et oui parce qu'il y a ces histoires
bien évidemment Fab antiriche et et de
de délai ouais ouais ouais je comprends
bien
mais je trouve ça enfin quand les mecs
jouent en réel sur un échitiier là-bas
autant quand ils sont chez eux je
comprends que la chesscom prennent
vraiment toutes les mesures et qui ce
délai là de 30 ou 60 secondes au m est
bien sûr qu'il y a pas de triche mais là
quand ils sont dans une salle tous
ensemble en présentiel peut-être que ils
pourrait ne pas y avoir ouais non mais
tu sais non non mais ouais non pourquoi
pas mettre un peu de tlé quand même dans
tout dans les tournois présentiels il
commence à y en avoir et même quand il y
en a on est plus sûr donc pourquoi pas
ouais ouais bien sûr mais là bon comme
ils sont peu
nombreux je penseon peut bien les
fouiller tu pens qu'un voilà tu penses
que voilà Maxim mtenant les coups sont
en avance sur la caméra donc on a bien
le le bon lien on est très bien on est
très bien euh non parce que oui les
tournois souvent en fait il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de monde je sais pas quand là
j'étais à la Coupe d'Europe il y a
quelques mois
OK as des centaines de joueurs tu peux
pas fouiller tout le monde intégralement
un peu compliqué donc tu fais au hasard
là ils sont
h je pense tu peux t'en sortir
ouais après sont des petites sécurités
après c'est là là là où où je vais faire
un peu l'avocat du diable l'avocat de
Lange en fait d'accord avec toi c'est
que je trouve que une minute de délai du
coup ça a pas un énorme impact que une
minute ou zé je suis d'accord que la
différence est quasiment nulle alors que
ouais tu peux faire une bonne demi-heure
1 heure 2h he décalage là bon non mais
pour du rapide 15 juste 10 minutes ça
suffit largement même 5 une minute c'est
vrai je trve que ça pas un énorme impact
si tu veux tricher ben une minute
ou et tu vibres et tu vibres
exactement on va dire moi je suis plutôt
pour le délai mais plutôt mis plus
quoi
après je pense que ça change pas
grand-chose dans les deux cas c'est bien
c'est
parfait beau tournoi avec un beaucoup
d'argent en jeu ah ouaisou c'est pas mal
je crois qu'il y a 200000 pour le
vainqueur al c'est que d'ailleurs sur ce
tournoi là ça compte pas tout ce qu'ils
ont pu gagner déjà dans les tournois
qualificatifs précédent tout au long de
la saison donc un beau petit
pctle et je crois que même si tu finis
bon dernier tu prends quand même 12000
ou un truc comme ça c'est pas mal ouais
place qui a priori a l'air promise à
lazavic mais il y a quand même ikarou
peut-être ikarou ouais pour l'instant le
concurrence pour l'instant le
concurrence en tout cas on attend Maxime
qui s'est levé
ah il entamé le Concord de marche c'est
beau remettre la caméra où on le voit
bien comme il faut marcher ah bah
voilà belle scène je dois dire avec les
écran derè tout c'est assz sympathique
les LED et tout c'est bien bien bien
ficelé avec les sponsor
leing
peut-être bientôt voir le display alors
que l'ordinateur aime pas du tout le le
coup de de saut que Maxime semble avoir
réfuté d'après l'ordinateur à
tempo bon en même temps je crois qu'il
était un peu obligé de jouer ce cou
ouais la dame était perdu
ou non la vente de l'ordi bon elle elle
est sympa elle est trouvable après je
sais pas à quel point ça c'est de faire
fou G3 en fait c'est de il veut faire
une pression sur cette diagonale et
l'ordi il voulait prendre c'est prend D4
c'est prendre des4 cavalier prend
cavalier prendre le cavalier perdu parce
le P 5 est cloué mais on va contreclouer
tout s se déclouant là c'est c'est
technique comme coup dame C5 pour aller
récupérer le le CAH
D4 donc si c'était le cas on aura un
pion de plus juste bon les blancs a
priori pourrait aller prendre quand même
B7 et ça pourrait juste vite tout
simplifier quoi
ouais même probablement mais ce serait
bien
sa je pense qu'il est jamais contre une
petite simplification
[Musique]
ou lui il veut peut-être lui il veut
gagner il veut faire deux nuls prendre
les Noirs à l'armagadon et refaire une n
ça lui fait
plaisir et au niveau des pauses alors ça
se passe comment je sais pas euh j'ai
trouvé que c'était un peu long entre les
parties et je crois qu'il y a une pause
d'une demi-heure entre les matchs donc
là c'est le premier match après Maxime
la 3è ronde il y aura une 4e ronde
j'imagine euh sur le coup peut-être de
20h15
20h30 je ne sais pas s'il y a un
planning déjà
prêt et basiquement vu la cadence euh
allez on peut compter 40 45 minutes par
partie si ça va un peu loin
euh ça joue en gros
6 par jour quoi voilà pour être bien sûr
S c'est non mais c'est bien ça permet
aux joueurs quand même cette moi je suis
plutôt pour la posuse entre les entre
les deux matchs que tu peux pas
enchaîner 5h d'échec la file était
obligé de faire
un petite respiration c'est tout à fait
normal
Fabien et c'est même complètement euh
positif
exactement on dit dans le chat que
ikarou a un point quel
point alors peut-être tu marques un
point en
il a dû perd en perdant un arm mais non
tu m pas de Pom l'armagon ça je sais
mais alors il a zé ENF il a perdu
peut-être que la personne a vu ikarou
ouais avant l'armagison il s pas rendu
compte qu'en fait ouais il faut gagner
les matchs he gagner une partie ça ça
sert à rien ou une nul ça marque pas de
points en fait ce qui marque des points
c'est de gagner des
matchs et ouais et je crois que donc il
y aura pas de gcche au candidat jefier
juste ah mais il encore un tourno pour
gouche quand même il vont faire encore
autre chose B oui il joue à Londres et
mais pas de bol s'il avait pas le petit
tourno en quand même il y aura un petit
tourno en
Inde quand même pas forcément pour lui
mais il y aura petit tournoi en Inde
important quand même
important ouis non mais c'est serait
dommage quoi non ce serait pas de
bol ce serait vraiment pas de bol s
avait pas le tournoant en Inde Doncel
qui afléchi beaucoup qui a fléchi à
faire des
PR5 il a perdu du coup aujourd'hui ouais
contre Hans bon les échecs on parlait
les de même du C il perd des points l en
plus c'est ça
euh possible
je je suis pas vraiment passionné he
pour ce tournoi je veux dire tu
vois je je regardais comme ça d'
distrait de loin quoi alors il a fait
fou G5 Westley donc il a enlevé le fou
qui éta attaqué pour contre-attaquer la
tour D8 et pas de fou G3
euh il a perdu 4,5 points gche ça
continue et Maxime qui ie la qualité
ilico tempo
[Musique]
euh ok sa a l'air un peu de suer non à
la
cam l' qu'il sue hein
ouais Maxim en tout cas qui clique hein
ça joue
vite et donc bah l'intérêt hein de
prendre ici donc il va laisser la tour
D8 si S veut prendre il va il va
reprendre il va y avoir un pion pour la
qualité et surtout le foot cas noir
masétien pourrait-on dire qui va
justement rayonner sur les cases noires
et lui donner de très belles
compensation donc il a pris des8 to
reprends et sur pion prend des qu il va
reprendre du cavalier j'imagine et sur
cavalier prendre prendre du Fou et ce
fou sera installé au centre de chiqué et
on voit tous les pions sur case blanche
plus de pièces non plus pour couvir ses
cases noires euh il y a plus de fou il y
aura plus de cavalier et et en plus Max
qui aura sa majorité depis dame et qui
pourrait songer à l'avancer et euh pour
pas faire une dame pourquoi pas faire
une dame qui contrôlera elle aussi les
cases noir donc là domination totale sur
case noire il pas mal he quand même la
maxime
h on le voit la jauge hein de toute
façon il est
serein non c'est clairement un des il y
a plus d'argent dans ce tournoi qu'au
championnat du monde de Blitz c'est
rapide hein faut-il le rappeler c'est un
gros objectif hein pour tous les joueurs
c'est peut-être le tournoi et le plus
d'argent de l'année en
fait bien possible he après les matchs
Championnat du Monde évidemment mais
derrière le match championnat du monde
j'ai bien l'impression que c'est
le ah B tournoi beau tournoi bah j'ai
pas idée de où il y aurait plus d'argent
que
ça je sais pas
les grand chestour il y a moins
non ouais les grandest ils ont un petit
peu marqué le pas là il font moins de
trucs ils sont moins révolutionnaires
quoi
ou ils sont mou quoi
ok donc intéressant la position pour le
coup en plus Maxim a pas mal d'avance à
la pendule euh et donc j'imagine il va
essayer de bah de monter ses pions sur
l' dam
he donc essayer de faire à 6 B5
C4 et puis encore avancer petit à
petit ça réfléchi côté
Westley 6 donc
okcoup de placement on va dire qui en
plus ben ouvre la colonne D pour pour la
tour face à la dame et donc se
questionner côté West un moment il
peutoir découvertes des choses comme ça
En tout cas westle qui tenteou d'aller
pousser ce pion F pour bloquer les cases
noir B ouais il a besoin des PS sur case
noir pour les bloquer
ouais soit pour faire5 soit peut-être
faire F5 coulisser la dame F5 F6 j'y
crois pas trop je suis pas inquiet pour
le RO de Maxime mais bon faudra quand
même y
songer position est complexe les deux
joueurs peuvent gagner
ouais ouais ouais c'est
euh as raison mais on dur dur de de
faire un
pronostic alors que là la j j'aime pas
du tout les dernier coup de Maxime
ouais euh rash là il a pas trop aimé la
jauge je vois que mais bon rfit je peut
comprendre il veut se libérer la ce G8
pour la tour éventuellement sil a un F5
qui part il pourrait peut-être faire g
pr e pr et
euh pourquoi pas je sais
pas je crois que Maxim il a pris la
décision de cliquer en fait il Enie les
coups Noro pas du tout qu il il réfléchi
à fond fume quoi ça fume mais bon
maintenant de toute façon il s'est mis
il va être obligé de jouer un peu vite
il a plus que 4 minutes peut plus
plomber trop trop
[Musique]
hein et euh alors là de l'air c'est
comment parce que je vois qu'on l'a
sur les indications donc ces boîtiersing
al la qualité de l'air tu as bien raison
d' d'en parler Fabien parce que c'est
quand même assez déterminant écoute elle
a l'air correct faire
ok mais c'est sûr que c'est dommage de
d'organiser le le tournoi sur place et
de pas réussir à avoir une qualité d'air
optimale et ouais plus le Canada
normalement l'air est pur ouais après en
intérieur et ils ont peut-être pas pu
bien ouvrir les fenêtres ou quoi mais
c'est ce que je me disais que peut-être
après plusieurs jours jours de tournoi
euh ça pourrait peser et que les joueurs
peut-être qui ouais en tout cas ça
pourrait les empêcher de développer un
un niveau de jeu optimal on verra Fabien
ça tout au long de de la compétition
j'espère que c'est pas ça qui qui
expliquerait les les petites
imprécisions de Maxime ça peut ça
peut
dame 7
ok je crois que Maxime est complètement
à côté en fait j'ai l'IM que il joue des
coups il joue des coups rien F rien
c'est je sais pas où il veut en
venir mais bon en même temps pourquoi
pas la position se ressemble toujours
mais du coup so il a quand même fait de
trois trucs il était une position de
base où il avait pas trop de contrôle
des case noir il Arve à mettre un pion
F4 il propose l'échange de ces fous
là et
[Musique]
euh et ais c'est vrai que ce roi G8 on
aurait été content qu'il soit là parceon
aurait pu faire fprend C 4 d' prend C4 d
prend E4 là malheureusement il y a le P
F7 en l'air
ouais et le roi qui était supposément
mieux placé en H8 finalement devient
moins bien placé ce que j'arrive pas
trop à comprendre dans ce TR H8 c'est
que de toute façon euh je vois pas ce
qu' pouvait lui arriver de mal en G8 en
fait
h bon après c'est pas encore gagné pour
les blancs parce que ça va être
difficile d'avancer quand même non mais
pour le coup comment dire autant de base
on pouvait être on savait pas trop qui
allait gagner ou quoi mais pourquoi pas
là en fait on a l'impression que
finalement les Noirs vont vraiment jouer
pour défendre alors c'est pas pour
autant que c'est perdant mais que après
ils peuventer aussi les Noirs
maintenant tu vois même les pion on est
pas arrivé à les avancer on dis tiens la
majorité ça a l'air cool si on peut
avancer
avec A4 ou quoi c'est bien bloc à tout
ça le fou C4 qui règne en mtre sur les
cases blanches à
Dame il7 d'ailleurs ça se voyait que
c'était un peu que c'était une faute pe
mal
placer on l'a
senti
alors qu'on dit le classement affiché
sur la page event de chesscom n'est pas
correct et oui voilà c'est pour ça qu'on
avait pas les bonnes
ref d'accord information quand même
assez importante parce que ça aurait pu
ça nous a pas trompé nous parce qu'on
suit quand même le tournoi mais c'est
vrai que si le classement sur la page
officielle du tournoi est mauvais ça
peut ah ça peut indire des g peut des GG
ouais ça c'est
sûr alors là apparemment faute faute
d'après qui d'après la la turbine mais
c'est vra que ce a 5 finalement il va
peut-être débloquer la la situation pour
pour Maxime bah du coup so qui voulait
pas juste bloquer avec ce pion A4 mais
qui veut venir attaquer la chaîne de
pion
donc je peux entendre ce qu'il fait en
soi mais finalement si Maxime arrive à
mettre la marche avant et à pousser ses
pions avir deux pions passé li soutenu
par le fou bon ça pourrait ça pourrait
très bien se passer tout d'un coup dame
C6
donc ça peut-être lui permettre de jouer
avec
B5 et ou
C4 il reprend un peu les cases
blanches partie étonnante parce que en
fait ça va dans un sens ça tourne un peu
ça ça retourne dans l'autre sens ou
partie
tbillonante je sais pas ce coup m'a
l'air aussi bizarre de lâcher case 5
comme
ça après il veut s'ouvrir la colonne F
quand même le F5 je le comprends plus
honnêtement on va
voir en tout cas de de mon point de vue
Fabien il donne quelque chose pour pour
enagner pour gagner autre chose quelque
part il tro il trque giving something to
get
else toujours important Fabien de d'être
capable de parler en anglais si jamais
il y a des événements
internationaux de faire des des des
castes bilingues donc parfois tu vois je
préfère quand même m'entraîner aussi
tout au long de de ces commentaires bah
surtout voilàre là en anglais tu vois
aussi
is on il échange une fois en B6 ça j'ai
envie de dire c'est léger de
conséquenceattendais de toute façon
tard mais ouais là tout un coup je suis
plus confiant dans la position de
Maxime il y a quelques coups F en C4 et
tu arriv à t'installer avec le fou
peut-être plutôt même en E5 a avancé bah
ouis PE
ça prend forme hein les
puntos
ah surtout que tu peux mettre le F E5 et
le pion F6 si tu veux
pour pour mettre un petit muret pour
mettre un petit muret ouais taper de
l'autre côté et après avancer
ok dame C4 il veut pas voir B5
hein sur dame 4 je suppose qu'il veut
prendre en G6
ou F6 et tour B6 et ouais ou F6 et tour
B6 en profitant du clou
Maxime qui a l'avantage à la pendule
l'avantage au temp ah ça ça
compte ça ça compte comme tu dis Fabien
B on l'a vu au début il a joué vraiment
vite l'ouverture vite et bien et bah c
avance qu'il a prise il l' toujours
et et donc à la fin quand ça jouer à des
détails qui aura plus trop de
temps ça peut faire la
DIF dam C qui prépare peut-être son
arrivée fracassante sur case noire Fab
ouais l'empereur des cases
noires dark square Emperor qui a déçu
hier éliminé très tôt dans le dans le
tournoi H3 ça ça donne vraiment trop de
cas noir est-ceon peut faire dam G3 à un
moment et placer le fou derrière à voir
peut-être alors là c'est peut-être un
peu tôt parce qu'on peut se faire
chasser par des tours F3 et compagnie
donc c'est pas encore dramatique pour
les blancs mais
bon c'est assez original comme manière
de défendre mais ça a l'air de passer
pour le
moment les jeux c'est les échecs c'est
un jeu vraiment concret hein si ça
marche ça marche hein ouais et ça passe
avant tout autre considération mais
[Musique]
euh mais
bon ça peut mal se passer un moment
quand même pour je pense toutes leses
histoir on va voir comment Maxime nous
joue ça il fait tour D6 donc il vient
bien surprotéger le pion B6
euh très bien donc il y a pas de
problème sur F7 pour l'instant la dame
fait le
boulot t F3 donc il veut doubler les
tours et peut-être prendre en G6 ou
faire F6 à un moment euh ça reste rest
double tranchant quand même hein c'est
très coupant
ouais parce que tu vois mine de rien tu
peux imaginer même sur un système tu
vois tu fais F F5 F6 qui prennent avec
une tour en F1 qui se fasse G4 G5 fait
la tour en F3 la dame en C4 tu défends
un peu toutes les ces blanches
bizarrement et tu peux te mettre tout
sur case blanche quoi
ouais pour ça que Maxime veut réattaquer
je pense HM rattaque4 attaque E4 cette
fois il a l'air vraiment prenable
attention il quand même F7 hein qui
ouais
mais bon là faut calculer
euh al l' propose G5 bah ça l'air
logique pour garder la colonne F fermé
hein
mais mais ça double
tranchant
double tranchant ça si on fait G5 F6
dame 5 on est
bien prend vraiment toutes les cases
noires on
empereur les cases de ma en plus
G5 pour faire G4 nousmême h sera
peut-être pas possible à cause des dam
H4 ou quoi donc il le joue Maxime voir
et la tour qui pourrait C ver h6 il peut
avir des idées d'aller contrer Lab
ro
il a pas l'air très William
S displ regarde ah ou on les a
raté j'ère qu'on les reverra les en
sponsor c cool ça ou fait des je les
toujours
derrière plus de
dis pr Mme au lieu de mettre
Maxim en camé display de partout quoi
display de Maxim
ouais en tout cas c'est bien joué tour 1
pour défendre le pion bien
évidemment ça
défend ce sont des jolis coups
Fab mais je je suis pour Maxim en
fait je me jette à l'eau un petit peu
pour un petit pro et on du G t G3 ok
Ilou attention il a pasage
4ou par
Maxim par wesle aussi ah
oui4 Jol C du coup 4 qui vient attaquer
la tour attaquer même les deux tours en
rayon X
[Musique]
et PE du qui arver aussi à un
moment clou aussi le
pche ça l'air plutôt bien
joué bien joué m plutôt très bien joué
de la part de Maxime
franchement il fait sa partie on va voir
si s'il fait il l'a fait donc vraiment
une jolie variante ce t prend G4 où les
blanc se retrouver maté il gagnent la
dame mais ils se font mat avec la tour
qui couiss en H6 sur case noir et le
fameux fou des 4 qui qui prend la G1
donc West ne va pas pouvoir prendre en
G4 mais du coup il a T G3
attaqué et il a que la dame qui peut les
défendre que prend avec le
fou dame des3 jou jou
ouais ça s'envole côté jauge Maxime
Maxime Maxime qui trouve qui fait juste
H5 qui défend tout qui défend tout et
qui va l'emporter Fab ouais bah ouais
mais c'était comment
dire c trou sur case noire en fait je
sais pas enfin l'ordi disait rien
pendant longtemps mais d'un point de vue
humain et
visuel un peu pour quoi
donc il a pris fait Atta découverte sur
la dame
f6on après il a plus de temps aussi là
il a plus que 6 secondes
donc on va on attaque tout en fait et on
aura quand même TR pions pour la
qualité bon écoute c'est une journée
qui Maxime qui gagne ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle aller on peut aller voir les
autres les autres parties après cette
victoire
allez ça a fait nul on peut aller voir
l'autre joueur français ah contre
ikarou
ikarou ikarou qui qui a les blancs
d'accord donc on se met côté noir côté
alira attends on est à l'envers
malheureusement c'estàd qui a les blancs
et qui les blancs ou
ouais les caméras sont à l'envers on est
un peu à l'envers de tout là euh on est
un peu à l'envers de
tout c'est plus les blans qui a les noir
femmes lesou les
blanc c'est
ça et ouais donc Ilou pas en forme un Z0
sur 2 al resa lui qui qui fait son petit
bonhomme de chemin dans le tournoi et
euh et quoi dire dans cette position
égalité matérielle
euh mais des pions un peu faibles
peut-être là chez les Noirs à voir bon
ça l'air d'aller hein mais les de on
peut on peu de temps il y a 22 secondes
contre 45 donc ça va se finir de toute
façon ça va
cliquer c'est vraiment la partie à
gagner hein pour alirea s'il pouvait
battre ikarou tê sous
l'au intéressant de voir le le niveau
d'ikarou quand même ouais alors non
c'est l'ordi n'importe quoi
ouais désolé fausse alerte comprenez pas
sur le coup d'amass en fait du coup
alors raisonnable mais bon si si cout un
tout noir on dit bah il aa une tactique
mais pas du tout bug parti des bugs donc
il fait C4 ilut se donner la case pour
la dame justement C5 pour taper sur F2
et pousser son pion passer au passage
ouais mais c'est peut-être un punto
aller manger là-bas en A3 et ben
peut-être toutçon ça va si c'est gratuit
il faut aller hein et c'est gratuit t B7
jouer très vite pression sur la 7e
rangée on peut pas aller contre-attaquer
euh fait dame à 5 ah il contreattaque
voir dame C7 au passage donc c'est pas
mal joué de la part d'alireza qui défend
et attaque en même
temps partie difficile hein pour pour
ikarou tour F c'est logique je trouvece
ou mais du coup tour un peu passive dame
D5 bien joué aussi pourchanger les dames
attention men de mat il défend qui
défend
tout ça clique
fort et peut-être on va menacer des k
prend H5 hein
puisque G3 est cloué com on a desac sur
G2 peut-être pr H5 c'est un coup je sais
pas B1 c'est un peu bizarre jou du coup
on vair faire soit4 so que j'allais dire
et revenir en B7
peut-être attention ça peut être
dangereux qui revient il fallait éviter
les f63 qui PV
arriver SAF peut-êre t F8 alors j'is
bien dame
C8 apparemment l'ORD donne complètement
gagnant et T pr F6 prend F6 ouais ça a
explosé côté alza ko qui qui nous a fait
une belle séquence quand même là dommage
pour qui pourtant ait mis le
kimono il a mis le kimono kimono
ouais
can dommage pour
Alireza Maxime qui s'est imposé he hier
contre
ikarou ikou qui va peut-être marquer son
réveil c'est important pour lui de
gagner cette partie hein parce que bon
il ferme la marche du tournoi plus ou
moins enfin il est dans le groupe des
des joueurs qui ont perdu les deux
matchsa et qui qui signe qui sert la
main qui
s'incline il reste encore une
partie qui c'est Carlson avec les Blancs
contre Carana j'aurais pas forcément le
temps de de vous remettre les les bons
noms en bonne vous voyez qui est qui he
désolé oua ess vous les reconnaissez ici
on voit bien que c'est
Carlsen avec les pièces
blanches norvégien en plus qu'on ne peut
pas confondre physiquement un brin
contre un
chatin avec les caméras sont petites
AR un arbitre qui s'était très très bien
placé là juste c'est fait un petit écran
noir de joueurs à de sur de jusqu'à
maintenant rappelle il y a deux places
qualificatives simplement pour pour les
autres de la place 3 à 6 il faudra
passer par un barrage là c'est sûrement
je sais pas les de Meur joueurs du
moment
quoi qui a repris une belle forme qui
vient de redépasser les 2008 d'ailleurs
c'est les deux seuls Jeurs à plus de 200
à V dire et Carlsen toujours Carlsen
quand même quoi même s'il n'est plus
champion du
monde on peut quand même pas dire qu'il
est l'OM de lui-même
non surtout dire qu'il est en train de
lui travailler au corps he
celle-là B écoute il est un pion de plus
il essaye he donc normalement c'est une
position qui doit se tenir pour Fabiano
mais il y a pas trop de temps donc une
gaffe peut être vite arrivé car on sait
qu'il a une bonne technique s bien
agancer ses pièces TR les faire
travailler qui a une harmonie et c'est
ce qu'il essaie de faire ave ce qui all
E4 qui est bien central qui défend F2
euh mais bon voilà tour fou a c'est un
meilleur tem normalement que tour
cavalier il réussi à systématiquement
mettre focales contre cavalier comme
voir
ici pas bien cliquer mais on voit la
focale donc il a du mal il est cloué il
est moins bien pour faire F4 F5 avec les
Blancs déjà avanc son pion
passé mais pas si simple mais c'est son
plan évidemment s'il arrive ça sera déjà
un premier progrès dans la position
3 pour faire F4
ensuite alors il rat AC ce pion F2
est-ce qui va redescendre le roi de
défendre n faire F3 mais bon F3 il aur
du Tour H2 qui pour partir donc il
redescend le
roi va mettre la tour à priori
ouais il veut garder les tours he pour
défendre ok ça y est il essaye
F4
donc nouvelle tentative
is mais là sur ro D4 il déjà F F6
ouais ro des c'est coup qu'on av envie
de
faire ça être échec échec il essay il
essaye bon là le truc c'est que même si
carwana juge que FC si c'est dangereux
il pour faire fouion et laisserersaire
qui avec tour et
cavalier ce niveau de jeu est nul assez
facile
niveau amateur ça peut gagner encore t
fou c'est un peu tendu même tour
cavalier joli
fait force les
échanges pas de case où aller se ccher
mais il réussi quand même à à bloquer le
roi ah non même pas il a pas pris il a
pas pris de la tour les deux joueurs qui
vont faire nul et ça va nous offrir
cette première pause Fabien donc
victoire de Nakamura contre firouja
victoire de Maxime contre West West et
nul dans les parties d'adorov lazavic et
Carlsen carwana on prend une petite
respiration combien de pausees fa je
sais pas trop je sais pas trop mais on
on guettete du coin de l'œil et on
revient et puis peut-être on peut mettre
une petite page sponsor voilà à tout de
suite les
[Musique]
amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et Fab nous sommes nous sommes enfin
repartis nous sommes presque repartis on
voit que les joueurs se sont enfin
installés ils sont allés récupérer on
comprend ils ont besoin Fabien d'avoir
cette énergie pour montrer leur leur
puissance optimaleiss niveau de je max
euh et donc Maxime avec cl blancs bah
qui est serein qui a gagné la première
partie avec les Noirs c'est jamais
facile et du coup là il peut se
contenter d'une petite nulle
donc donc il est bien dans ce match on
va dire il est bien bien bien là comme
j'ai plus trop de j'ai du mal à le faire
bien
bien prendre les TR points il boit sa
petite gorgée d'eau il
s'hydrate il a bien
raison on attend un petit peu comme vous
on sait pas exactement quand ça va
reprendre a priori inement sous peu les
joueurs sont ass alors c'est chiqu
je trouve que ça va quand même assez
vite he très franchement c'est c'est ça
enchaîne quand même relativement
rapidement les parties là ils ont ils
ont terminé on a vu car terminé c'est
quoi même 10 minutes de de pause à peine
10 15 max 10 15 minutes max
ouis c'est ça enchaîne ça enchaîne
vraiment vite c'est
le c'est le spectacle avant tout bien
évidemment dans dans ces tournois pas de
pause à allonge d'une heure ou 1hure et
de entre les parties on se contente
simplement d'unun petit quart d'heure
peut-être je pense qu'il vont repartir à
19h on se contente d'un petit quart
d'heure il y aura une pause Mme ça
repart dès maintenant non tu vois même
peut-être même pas on se on se conente
peut-être de 10 minut 57 on regardera
pour pour savoir la prochaine fois
faudra qu'on note Fabien peut-être une
petite pireque de son ou il doit garder
les pièces parce qu'en cas de nul c'est
Maxime qui gagne exactement donc il joue
une Pier pour garder les
pièces on va voir Maxime va jouer il
fait G3 comme toi non il joue la
classique avec cavalier F3 je pense
qu'il a raison
petitck je pense que généralement ne pas
jouer contre moi et plutôt pas jouer moi
plutôtouis un bon conseil
ouaisil il fait fou TR ok je connais pas
je me conseilleraiis moi-même en fait de
ne pas jouer comm moi euh bon moi
jeurais avec fou G4 avec les Noirs assez
vite donc voilà je peux plus le faire et
du coup bah 6 serait le coup que je
jouerai moi
pas avec C6 pour ouais c'est Vlad il
joue plutôt avec C6 donc bon écoutez
Vlad pas moi mais moi moi j'aimais bien
jouer avec A6 B5 plutôt pour pour mettre
le fond en B7 et une pression sur le
centre éventuellement et aussi pour que
le pion C7 puisse aller en
C5 avir des structures plus de
sicilienne ou de
ou de Benoni euh donc ouais moi j' sur
A6 c'est si possible et sinon évidemment
on peut jouer AC cavalier C6 pour bah
pour jouer 5
alors k C6 ça peut appeler le le coup D5
mais là avec un fou D3 en plus k B4 on
pour regagner un temps dessus mais sinon
la plupart du temps juste le le cavalier
repart en en B8 et après on fait E6 ou
C6 et on attaque le le
centre attends le coup de Wesley
hein
ouais qui hésite qui a fléchi mais
faudrait pas il fait ce qu'il veut c'est
pour lui qu' se remette mal a temp la
partie précédente parce qu'il il a perdu
en grande partie à cause de ce retard
accumulé en début de partie à la pendule
et là on part sur sur les mêmes
bases6 et probablement5 va
partir du coup si Maxime ve rien faire
spécial n lu il va prendre je
pense
que D5 ça complique le
jeu en des symétrique
donc no en fait une parti
F très symétrique passe pas mass de
choses le chix Maxime sachant suff
absolument
excellent
magnifique partie pas pas super embante
pour le moment pas trop
bah après c'est aussi les les matchs
allerretour quand quelqu'un gagne avec
les Noirs généralement ça donne ce genre
de partie au retour
puisque gagne avec les Blancs on a envie
d'imposer la la
patte entre prendre du cavalier du
pion Maxime qui se barre déjà ah le
displate oui ah non mince c'est quoi ça
mais j'ai pas le displate contemp à
chaque fois j'ai le seum je suis
tellement heureux d'avoir le
displate je sais pas ce que c'est ce
sponsor je je reconnais pas le logo en
fait c'est une sorte de d'Antarctique
non ça êre beau logo après il y a pas de
pas de pas de souci là-dessus mais le
display fait toujours tellement plaisir
quand je le vois arriver les autres font
très plaisir aussi attention le Hings
bien évidemment le Meetup aussi qui est
beau le Aness
aussi Aness pris du Kaval ouais j'ai pu
tester la beta en plus de Aness
monchange tout toi tu dois pas connaître
Aness Aness an regarde c'est le sponsor
on parle sponsor il y a quelque chose à
voir avec anich alors pas du tout mais
c'est un c'est un jeu un jeu d'échec
avec avec des des sorts j'ai pu tester
la beta comment ça des sorts tu c'est un
peu tê sur les
chiqu ouais un petit peu ouais tu en
sorcell genre tu as pasit de bouger ta
dame quoi genre ça ta dame ne peut plus
aller en diagonale
ou peut plus reculer je coupe une
oreille c'est à peu près ça ouais ok et
c'est sympa tuas un bon
sorcier tu mais ton ton chapeau de de
Marl l'enchanteur ouais non c'était dur
pour moi j'ai mal joué quand j'ai joué
on dit qui contrôle la scène attendez je
voudrais voir dans le chat j'ai
l'impression on a un problème et
j'arrive pas à comprendre lequel attends
je suis un tout petit peu qui est fa si
tu m'as vu tout d'un coup vois qu' y a
des gens qui all la régie qu'est-ce qui
se
passe mais j'ai l'impression que ça
va ah c'était l'OPI logo voilà c'est
pour ça ça ça ça écrivait je me disais
ah tiens ah oui alors tu sais qu'on a un
petit problème c'est que le chat il en
décalé par rapport à oui oui non je sais
je sais évidemment
oui d'ailleurs le chat enfin bon moi je
le vois pas mais si on vous répond pas
trop c'est vrai qu'on a unc d'une minute
avec vous oui c'est pour ça que j'ai
j'ai eu un un
un un coup de un coup de de de stress et
euh et donc Swan chas ça va
être il veulent le sortir et que ce soit
une sorte honnêtement j'en sais pas
beaucoup plus après tu sais moi tu VO on
me donne à tester des choses et tu
testes et tu fais un retour ou juste tu
testes et puis tuas testé non
euh alors tu veux que je te parle très
franchement maintenant actuellement
ouais pour faire un retour je demande de
l'argent non mais je te le dis
franchement en fait j'ai beaucoup fait
de retour gratuitement maintenant non tu
donnes plus d'info quoi non non mais
franchement je ne lâcherai aucune info
on sait pas si c'est bien ou si c'est
mal y a pas ouais il y a pas il y a pas
de PU avec cette visue mais pas très
important pour le moment on met on met
l'autre visu en fait quand le temps de
devient important ou donc je ne
te je ne te lâcherai pas in mais
peut-être que c'est très bien peut-être
pas perso donc j'ai pas joué donc mon
avis pas grand chose mais je sais pas je
sens pas qui personnellement
mais tu lâch bet je te donner mon avis
après
stream
[Musique]
sin je men
fous B3 le fou ver3
bon position bien
symétrique attends on nous dit une œuvre
d'art unique sur un poster display de
haute qualité signé par les deux
finalistes réservés le vôtre dès
maintenant mais j'ai carrément envie de
le
faire tu veux participer au bah j'aime
bien moi j'aime bien displate en fait je
kiffe la marque je display je tu viens
donner un avis là quand même oui mais
par qu'il m'ont payé
et mant qu'il payent plus quoi ouais
mais bon ils ont payé avant ça va c'est
beau
quoi c'est beau j'ai donné un avis
quoi tu ne m'exprimis pas sur cette
marque doncend ça a l'air de bien se
passer si vous voyez un petit peu
rigolard mesdames et messieurs c'est
juste qu'on voit pas du tout comment
Wesley pourrait même
tenter maxime est trop symétrique on va
attendre de voir quelques coups jouer
hein parce qu'après rien n'est jamais
àquis rien n'est jamais ta
quiis bon j'imagine qu'il va faire un
dame 8 ou dame 7 ou dame quelque part
quoi est-ce que s'il y a une finale
carlsel on repart à Paris pour refaire
un watch
party j'étais sûr que ça allait se
mettre en S j'ai fait exprès de le dire
parce que je voulais entendre ton
non je sais pas si renchou il
paye c'est t pareil c'est toujours c'est
tellement tu vois c'est quand même
toujours là j' sens que on a fait
beaucoup de Paris là déjà
c'est les gens qui sont très contents de
de la backup dire il a tellement de gens
qui m'ont écrit aujourd'hui quiimagine
même pas mais faudra que j'en discuterai
sur Twitter il faudra qu'on fasse un
petit débrief on fera peut-être un prél
à un moment donné ou un
truc c'est vra qu'il y a tellement de
gens il y a jamais autant de gens qui
vont écrire après un événement là cette
fois-ci c'est
impressionnant certains ont eu le seum
de ne pas y être les absons ont toujours
tort en même temps ils ont vraiment eu
tort là celle-là ils ont vraiment eu
tort il pouvait pas s'attendre au
benger que ça a étaéit c'était
c'était dur à prévoir
ouais bi là je sais même pas ce qu'on
peut dire en fait il a tout qui va
s'échanger c'est symétrique enfin ouais
bah il foquer le recul so il peut-êre
faire fou F8 ou un cou comme ça on va
échanger on fera une tour en D1 on
échange va faire 7 F 6 on va échanger
puis euh voilà
quoi puis rien
mais mais mais mais c'est très bien joué
de la part de Maxime enfin là c'est
absolument aucun reproche sur sur ce
qu'il fait lui joue de manre pro il doit
faire nul pour gagner le match et ben
faisons nul et puis à westle risqué il a
qu' pas jouer 6 5 en laissant des pr 5
possiblebl quoi ah bah oui non mais
c'est c'est
clair
après qui sait peut-être ça peut mal
tourner à un moment et puis on verra
mais pour l'instant c'est c'est maîtrisé
de la part du du joueur
français tour1 propose un nouvel échange
ok
oui a 6 donc il ve essayer de jouer avec
B5 il a raison point d'interrogation
mais parce que l'ordinateur forcément
n'évalue pas le côté obligé de gagner
[Musique]
mais là bon j'imagine Maxime va juste
échanger la tour et mettre l'autre en D1
pour contrôler la seule colonne ouverte
de l'i pu s a B5 B5 et puis le
fou F pourquoi pas
ver2 et rentrer avec la tour un
moment
adverse
l'ORD dit qui adore F4 he si vous voyez
la jauge ouais mais
bon bah dis donc non mais c'est question
de situation de match uneelle fois si tu
joues pour le gain F4 c'est trouvable
mais là ah bah oui tu mets une pression
tuouvres le jeu pendant que tu es mieux
mobilisé et tu fais jouer ton fou C4
avec la tour F1 connectée vers F7 donc
pourquoi pas mais là dans une sitation
nul suffit bon ben tuchanges fais tour1
ça a l'air hyper
logique mais bon après si
Maxime réfléchit bah c'est que oui il a
vu F4 je pense
et ben il va évaluer voir s'il y a un
risque ou pas parce qu' évidemment ça va
un petit peu changer le caractère de la
position pour le coup après F4 tu te
fais une moins bonne structure mais bon
si c'est très tu pr un gros avantage ben
tu peux ne pas t'en
priver moi je pense que je l'aurais fait
probablement même en obligation nul mais
parce que j'aurais eu peur de force de
rien faire tu fin par perdre faut faire
ga à ça quand même de mes spécialités
ça tiens je fais et puis force de
l'avoiravoir perdu des parties à la con
comme
ça non mais non non mais bien sûr je
connais un défaut donc je préfère aller
à l'encontre du défaut enfin je pense
qu'en fait j'ai un meilleur pour moi
personnellement mais je pense ça dépend
des
joueurs Maxime le
fait moi je pense que si je saisis pas
les opportunités après tuen veux
doncprès si j'ai pas fait une fois c'est
que toute la partie je vais être dans le
même mood ou donc mon adversaire va
abuser je sais pas là F4 c'est quand
même capacité trouver que ça marche faut
le faire et Maxime le fait d'ailleurs
donc un des problèmes pour les noirs de
base il aur biené faire t prendend F4
mais il font après tour8
per une pièce
quoi et sur prend F4 direct maintenant
Maxime il veut continuer par E5 5 6
peut-être et
avancer et bêtement on 5
donc
trouver non ça va être facile lev Maxime
d'ailleurs dans ce match beaucoup l pare
précédente là encore il est
bien il se
balade il parce que c'est facile parce
que c'est facile Fab tel un
chat démarche très
féline il meup alors ils font quoi je
monre pas d'info hein je juste qu'ils
font ok on en
parlera on en parlera plus tard DEAP
c'est prévu à Fab dans cette semaine on
porte pas limite tu pas fond ah ok
cool vous pouvez aller regarder hein et
il y a le display là do être très
heureux
display c'est magnifique
hein
ah le
Lofi ils vont quoi
c'est la musique le Lofi ch tuas pas vu
ils ont fait ils ont fait un morceau de
musique pour jouer aux échecs en Lofi
enfin musique Lofi pour jouer aux échecs
je sais pas ce que c'est Lofi en fait le
F c'est un peu chill quoi c'est cool
ok CR une musique qui te siè pour jouer
aux échecs et il ils font plein de
playlist lei ils ont fait un truc pour
les échecs mais c'est pas mal ok ok mais
c'est quoi c'est une sorte de Spotify
non c'est sur Youtube c'est unebe girl
je crois que ça
s'appelle c'est une vidéo quoi mais
c'est long c'est V à la musique quoi
c'est cool enfin vraiment cool tu peux
mettre
tu là un peu tu fais ton Célestin non
c'est plus calme
Lofi bon
j'écouterai je te recommande
ouais
donc là qui a choisi de de protéger son
pion E5 en échangeant la tour et mettre
le cavalier en D7 c'est pas
bête et le coup que Maxime va peut-être
jouer c'est F5 pour ne pas laisser
leséchang et avoir uneonne structure
maintenant avec cette case 5 qui pour
être bien pour le cavalier à terme
et et aussi ça ferait ça activerait le
le F
G7
il est-ce que F5 il pas aussi une idée
sur B5 de faire fou
E6
peut-être ou pas enfin je suis pas bien
sûr de moi quand
même 5 fa 6 puis on prend puis on prend
CAV F
E7 on sort le fot cas blanche on échange
tout en F8 et on a encore simplifié mais
est-ce qu'on a si envie je sais pas
pourquoi pas sinon B5 on fait pas fou 6
et on va juste reculer le fou pas en le
deux c'est sûrement le même le mieux
quoi peut-êre on fera G4 pour prendre de
l'espace à àroi les noir ont toujours
des petits soucis pour quand même finir
le développement parce que le on aim
bien faire fou B7 et tour D8 ou tour
quelque part mais bon bah là le fou C8
doit défendre le cahier D7 et et si on
veut d'abord bouger le cahier D7 et ben
il y a T D8 qui arrive donc ils sont un
peu un peu pâau avec leur pièces non ça
va être facile là pour Maxime j'imagine
pas
autre résultat que nul ou victoire de
Maxime ça quel que soit la la position
en fait en
général c'est Maxime tellement auudessus
de tout quand même tellement facile
là
si tour D6 c'est jouable ça pourrait
être une idée mais attention à fou F8
qui pourrait enfiler
ok toi c je par Wesley bon je pas un
coup quoi moi je ferai G4 probablement
ici marrant numéro 1 de l'ordi c'est
pour jouer l'idée justement du chat
c'est de commencer par F F e 7 puis
suivre par tour D6 et sur tour C7 tu
auras fou C8 HM D8
pardon joli coup fou e 7 pas évident
enfin je trouve G4 plus naturel quoi
mais euh mais une fois qu'on a l'idée
c'est vrai que on peut y
penser
d Maxim qui prend bien son temps moment
important
ouais ça a l'air facile mais il faut
quand
même rester concentré et et jouer les
bons coups pas se
désunir mais ouais ce fut ça vraiment
joli
cou enfin la difficulté le truc c'est
que c'est loin d'être le seul coup non
et est-ce que sur F7 F F8 on fait juste
F6 pour complètement
[Musique]
le faire suffoquer ouais ben c'est
suffoquant he he F 7 F F8 F6 il y a plus
une pièce qui
bouge il fait G4 donc le coup naturel he
j'ai envie de
dire non c'est pas simple fa c'est pas
des c'est pas un thème qu'on qu'on a
qu'on a l'habitude de voir et en plus
euh même il il vient pas spontanément ce
coup parce que westle vient de jouer
tour à 7 et on vient se mettre dans un
vis-avis
donc c'est juste dur à envisager une
fois qu'en fait on va leur dire en
parler ou quoi il y a plein de bonnes
raisons et ça marche très bien c'est
très fort et c'est joli d'ailleurs mais
mais j'ai4 oui c'est le c'est normal
quoi
être enwing toujours pareil hein
c'est pas obligé de
gagner c'est pe-être plus dur
aussi
bon probablement juste fou de
attaquer
e entre fou 2 ou fou F1 benah je sais
pas quoi
d'autre j'ai du mal à voir d'autres d'ut
coup possible en
fait
on se demande hier si le duo de barman a
bien géré et ben moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
été recruté comme barman est-ce qu'on
peut dire je suis un excellent barman
très
bien merci Fab j'ai ma reconversion be
métier
non parce que dispot avait laissé un
préposé au bar quoi du coup donc il
faisait son métier alors que nous bon c
plus de la reconversion et donc le poste
était tenu le poste était tenu
ouais
F6 bon l'ordi dit mauvais mais
enfin c'est très bien quand
[Musique]
même
5 son tour des 6 qui va
arriver tu VO que les noms sont pas bons
non c'est les cames qui s
ou
je suis en train de réfléchir en fait
comment
switcher en fait c'est pas fait pour
switcher les cam tu peux juste switcher
les noms
ok du coup ça donne envie de tourner j
ouais on voit bien que Maxim est
blanc du cou onve avec les noir en bas
qui VI jouer G5 pour pas que les blan le
fassent mais bon on imagine qu'il peut
jouer avec tour D6 pour rentrer dans le
camp adversequer le P en
C6 sur T C7 puis on bouge pas trop et
peut-être on pourrait même replacer
après le cavalier C3 via D1 E3 et
rebondirtion Maxime quand même
pas le pion F6 c'est un petit
risque ton là c'est très bien il bloque
bien les si un jour on vient à le perdre
bah on serait foutu
quoi c'est tout le problème
Fab après il est pas simple à attaquer
il le K qui l'attaque mais il est pas
prenable parce qu'on se vange avec tour
des 8 on fait une double attaque sur le
roi le8
euh mais bon il va vouloir faire8 à un
moment et qu' à menacer donc on fera
tour D6 et est-ce que les ns vont
essayer de faire un truc comme tour B7
tour B6 à un moment C5 l'ORD qu'il
veulent pour échanger cette tour de D6
et après mais ça a l'air dur à imaginer
mê que soit possible comme ça parce que
quand ils font C5 le cavalier qui vient
en
D5 et qui en plus protègera le pion j'ai
plus un plan comme ça ça ça ça ça ça et
ça
c'est je sais pas si on y arrive mais
genre il y a quand même un monde où si
tu fais rien avec les Blancs ça arrive
sû
ou
attendz 6
jouer tour C7 défond
pion Maxime s'est retrouvé moins bien
enfin moins bien aut temp ouais il est
un peu moins bien auut temps mais
c'est
il s'est un peu mis dans le problème
avec ce F6 quand même HM
ouais peut-être faut faire D1 qui 3 C F5
comme ça le 8 prend t des échecs en G7
quoi
attentionme la pendule comme tu l'as
signalé plus que une minute 30 pour
Maxime la qualité de l'air en train
d'EMP fa ah
non terrible plus en fer
là trucs en rouge
maintenant2 donc venir vers B4
ok8 a prend
B5 je pense va prendre de C ouais la
question je sais pas en fait mais de é
possible équilibré
quoi
ouais bon
F6 les enux sont
clairs Maxim attaque le pion
C6 avec le K B4 donc soit il va faire du
Fou B7 faire du K
B8 k B8 relativement logique ça
permettrait de faire fou 6 et se
développer avant de peut-être revenir
vers des 7 un peu plus
tard mais bon jamais çaok il a fait k
B8
ça va aller quand même
h le nombre de pions il pris du Fou donc
il laisse le pion G4
mais mais
bon un bou
C4
ouais non ça va ça va
passer ça va passer sans trop de
problème
Fab et bien manque d'activité quoi c'est
activité
d'espace même sur F en fait il y a pas
de de réfutation j'imagine mais si font
rien monte le roi F2 ou quoi on sait pas
comment les n bouger après parce que si
il a fait t des de d'as pour aller vers
G2 attaquer le fou
G5 ça paraît pas perdable en fait et où
tour H 2 pour pour rentrer de la
colonage al il rattaque le pionre T D6
retour attaque C6 et défend
F6 il repart bon Maxime peut répéter les
coups bien sûr s'il veut il ne s'en
prive pas d'ailleurs non c'est un des
seuls joueurs du circuit je pense qu'il
serait capable de répéter quand même
il va faire autre chose quand même mais
oui
est-ce qu'on se remettrait pas pour la
fin en grande vue en grande vue alors
attends on peut mettre ça comme tu veux
on se voit plus mais au moins on voit le
on voit les chis plus grand quand même
et au plus vous voyez les pendul
ouais ouais là on a un peu tout là là
c'est important là
c'est moins d'une minute
is non ça va pas pourir
gagner
6 ouais mais bon ça ça peut pas
gagner Maxime qui va récupérer le pion
de
Mos pion j'ai 5 dans la besace bientôt
ouais ça va s changé mais
euh
ouais
éch7
G5 F5 je pense qui
D3 mais
peuttre mais bon symboliquement mie qu
mmeetrouver un peu à su mais bon c'est
pas non
plus c'est dommage en fait de se
retrouver à devoir défendre
pas comme
ça
ou mais mais avec plus trop de temps tu
peux mal tourner regard lae en train de
la perdre Maxime c incroyable ais mais
il a SRI il a mal joué on l'a
senti t à 3 ouais il va faire ro prend
F6 après cavalier prend
même il y a
pas
a ou parce que 5 av encore t reprend le
5 à vrai dire mais ouais bon il y a tout
qui
tombe très mauvaise partie de Maxime
finalement on sait pas trop comment a
tourné mais à un moment donné petit à
petit on sait pas trop pourquoi étonnant
un peu
ouais on sait pas trop il a fait
peut-être un petit F6 mal timé à un
moment
ouais c'est une faiblesse long terme
quoi c'était un peu comme sa avec ses
ces blanches enfin noir la partie
d'avant ouais ve t reprends des 7 mais
c'est pas passé
une micro chance
encore il a encore une micro chance
Maxime S qui a pas été super
propre
c'est bien joué là quand même cavalier
D5 cavalier F4 ça va faire mal j'imagine
t D5 fait très très mal aussi
clou le tour va pas être trop dur à
gagner là ah il a réussi à faire les
bons échanges on va voir Maxime
s'incliner et on va avoir le droit en
armagadon
ouais ouais ben écoute ouais un peu
surpris parce que bon après la victoire
dans la première ronde et la position
qu'il avait là moi j'entendais pas du
tout une défat mais bon bravo à W qui a
cru
car ouais ça c'est
fait firoua qui s'est incliné une
deuxième fois contre ikarou perdu et
[Musique]
ilavic pour les
noir alors la zavi a les blancs donc
ouais ça doit gagner pour les Noirs mais
la zavic qui a été très très fort pour
arriver jusqu'à ce ce niveau de la
compétition après il marque un peu le
pas en finale peut-être sa trè défaite
en en trois matchs ça dur he sur chiqu
c'est il joue bien sur son ordi quoi
ouais donc un peu moins spécialiste du
du
truc que Al dit que c'est nul de
nouveau étonnant
aussi que G4 il TG
vite terrible pour AB qui rate
l'inratable mais ouais Maxim étonnant
comment il a perdu quand
même fait le problème des Noirs c'est
que donc dès qu'ils font G4 Mo jouer il
tour G8 et on n pas le temps de faire
tour à 6 avant parce que le RO vaer se
mettre en H3 et il nous bloque
quoi
tu décales la tour bah il décale la
sienne il fait dam oigé de rester sur la
colonne exactement TR fois la même
position déjà d'prè ce que j'ai compris
mais ah quoi que non il a changé de coup
finalement toute façon il pe pas
savoir je un truc c'est est-ce que là il
pouvait pas faire ro G4 à ce momentl ah
t G8 tout façonends ch rien en
fait
on a été mauvaise langue
farb AC un peu de réussite sen sort bah
je pense ça doit être foutu la finale
quand on l'a pris au début quand même
ouais je sais pas ce qu'il a fait il a
mal monté le roit enfin il a mal il a
laissé l'autre venir se mettre là-bas il
a pas eu ro F5 jouer c'est juste qu'ils
ont ils ont signé
nul bien évidemment sur ro F5 il aura eu
à 8 dames donc il va y avoir quoi Fab
pour pour résumer il va y avoir un
armaganon la match de Maxime Magnus qui
s
lazavav aussi un armagad on va pouvoir
se se délecter et firouja qui s'est fait
écraser écrbouiller par par Naka qui euh
qui revient un petit peu dans ce tournoi
du coup qui signe son premier succès
dommage que ce soit contre l'un des deux
joueurs français mais c'est comme ça
mesdames et messieurs on va faire une
petite pause et on revient très vite
pour l'armagadon je sais pas dans
combien de temps peut-être dizaine de
minutes ouais bah là falloir qu'il fasse
les enchères tout ça donc on vous
tiendra informé de de combien ils ont
pris euh hier carwana il pris contre
Maxime contre je sais
plus si contre Maxime il av pris 9 52
pour avir les
[Musique]
noir merci les amis à tout à
l'heure manage your air quality sharpen
your performance change the game with
air things a new opening for your wall
is here capture new major pieces on
unique metal posters from displate now
with the official collection from
Chess.com Mount them in seconds with a
toolfe magnet kit and swap them whenever
you like make your move get an exclusive
discount on all metal posters shop now
with the code chess at
displate.com
[Musique]
back
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs c'est c'est
reparti he côté côté Maxime en fait pour
pouvoir avoir plus d'infos on est obligé
nous-même de regarder le le stream en
anglais pour savoir un peu un peu ce qui
se passe qui prend qui qui prend quoi
pour avoir les les bonnes images on vous
recommande d'en faire de même et il se
trouve donc que westle a pris peu de
temps 857 c'est beaucoup plus que la
zavi qui abdf ouais ils ont pris 10
minutes euh donc mais Maxime qui a fait
la même chair que Fabiano hier 952
euh donc voilà bon al à la différence
de des parties qu'on vient de voir ils
auront pas de rajout quoi euh donc
Maxime qui a joué une une ouverture
anglaise et euh voilà pour que ça joue
quoi j'ai envie de dire et donc il
commence la partie avec beaucoup
d'avance he
Maxime qui voilà qui s 15
minutes un petit B4 jouer donc en fait
l'idée sur fpran c'est qui veut faire
qu' prend le 5 j'imagine est-ce que tu
peux nous rappeler l'enjeu Fab les de
l'ARM magadon tout à fait donc c'est un
format dans lequel les blancs sont
obligés de gagner et donc ils ont plus
de temps à la pendule hein vous voyezil
a commencé avec quasiment le double du
temps de son adversaire mais donc les
blancs doivent absolument gagner et les
noirs peuvent eux donc pour se qualifier
enfin pour gagner le le match faire nul
ou gagner la partie évidemment
euh donc voilà c'est euh bon c'est un
format qui utilisé des fois pour
départager les joueurs
quoiou moment bon voilà tu as deux
solutions pour départager les joueurs
quand ça arrive là soit tu fais des
cadences vraiment rapides genre 3 + 2
mort subite ouais c'est un peu petit
bonheur la chance de qui a les blancs en
premier ça peut être déterminé avant le
tournoi d'ailleurs genre C fois et enfin
un peu comme un apparillement blanc noir
en fait à l'avance pour que ça
s'équilibre
tu fa faire un shifoui quoi ou tu fais
faire un ouais
ou tu pourrais imaginer peut-être même
un puzzle rush enfin ouais et tu choisis
ta couleur celui qui gagne un petit
match aurait les les blancs et les Noirs
en premier mais donc que deux solutions
soit le mort subite en 3 + 2 et alors là
les gens vont te vont vous dire souvent
sur ce format là moi j'ai souvent
entendu la chose qui oui mais dans ces
cas-là ça peut ne jamais terminer tout
peut toujours arriver tout peut toujours
arriver d'ailleurs une partie peut durer
plus de 70000 couches une partie d'échec
donc là avec les plus 3 secondes par
coup je pense qu'on ser aussi proche de
l'éternité mais euh et l'autre solution
c'est l'Armageddon alors l'Armageddon on
est sur un armagadon à temps long
pourquoi pas après on c'est pas
forcément bon on garde les qu de B voilà
bah c'était le format qu'ils ont fait
toute l'année dans leur dans le circuit
ou ouais bon c'est pas habituel hein en
tout cas mais bon pourquoi pas c'est pas
habituel mais mais ça reste intéressant
c'est les deux solutions de toute façon
c'est soit armagadon soit mort subite
mais oui non mais la mort subite ça
arrive forcément à un moment enin je
veux dire aux échecs où il es obligé au
bout soit Armon soit mort subite tu peux
pas non non mais je veux dire enfin
l'argument comme quoi ça pourrait dur
éternellement en fait tu peux faire le
même pour une sance de T tu peux faire
le même pour un match de tennis ah bah
un point peut être éternel is oui déjà
rien qu'un point ou un break je pensais
mais oui enfin donc non mais un point
simplement peut être éternel
[Musique]
doncent tout peut-être éternel en fait
hein même un match de foot limité à 90
minutes si les mecs se blesse en boucle
des heures qui a des coupures de courant
enfin ou un match de rugby en fait la
88e passe ils vont jamais en touche quoi
ouais ah oui ça il le terrain il
marqueent jamais d'esss ils font rien
ils sont là euh ça peut être éternel
aussi pas avant il font pas de faute il
a rienargum quand Mme principal contre
le le mort subite au éche c'est pu
éternelche c'est
toujours particulier alors là attention
c'est un peu étonnant mais la dame
estfend coup plutôt bien joué de la part
de ce coup c qui vient attaquer le
centre blanc qui veut isoler un pion si
possible
euh écoute
Wes qui nous fait une bonne une bonne
partie il a pas beaucoup réfléchi il
arrive à avoir un truc
solide mais le je sais pas ça c'est mon
avis après faudra avoir les stats mais
je pense que
l'armagedon rapide comme ça tu peux
vraiment prendre 6 7 minutes enfin tu qu
Mme fair avec les j'ai l'impression je
sais pas c'est dur à
dire Maxime tu peut s'en vouloir en tout
cas le match il avait tellement ouis
c'était normalement il y a pas de monde
où il rate la partie d'avant il devait
juste faire nul avec les Blancs il était
vraiment mieux ouais et sans aucun
problème de rien il a fini par perdre le
contrôle
ah donc là il a vraiment l'air bien avec
les Noirs
ouais
match compliqué pour Maxim j'espère ça
pas lui mettre la tête sous
l'eau là vous voyez la jauge qui donne
avantage noir mais ça ça ça se voit
c'est simplement
visuel une qualité de plus
quoi VO seul truc tour B5 il vautêtre
trouver
Maxim faire N C7 t C5 dame D8
et tu peux pas faire tu peux pas faire
ouais ouais Maxime qui s'est fait
exploser en réité dans ce dans cette
partie on a même pas eu trop le trop le
temps de de voir ce qui se passait on a
vu que la position se détériorait très
vite et que c'était raté l'ouverture h
et Maxime qui s'est très rapidement
çatait joué quasiment tempo hein
ou il a joué tempo il a joué D3 et la
tempo il s pris pu on prend pu on prend
faut prend un cavalier d de ouais c'est
qu' a même pas bon ben en C7 c'est
sûr Maxime peut tellement s'en
vouloir alors l'ordi donne pas trop
grave après dame A4 ça va peut-être
avoir c'est une double attaque 6 5
sortir il va tenter il a vraiment du B
quité netteit dans l're
sens n
aussi
mais en fait on
est en fait du
coup là c'est aussi faute non mais parce
que parce qu' nul si jamais
ou 4 la force c'est que ça tap la tour
au passage c'est vraiment une très
mauvaise partie de Maxime
ouais sûrement mis un coup au
[Musique]
moral cette partie précédente
ouais mais mainten rne avantage après d
cétait apparemment de pas
répéter pas
répéter je crois que
fou c'est logique je dire tu protèges
bien ton fou 5
prob
demain bon écoutez on va voir la Jae je
crois qu'elle est qu'elle fait n'importe
quoi en fait dur à
dire ça repart dans le scénario un peu
de la grunf il sa qualité de moin non
mais je pense qu'il y a eu pas mal
d'erreur là oui oui part d'autres dans
la séquence après dur de dire exactement
quel
coup bon ça peut bien tourner finalement
pas une partie de de qualité mais ça
peut bien tourner F6 il tente le muret
alors je sais pas est-ce qu'il y a des
découvertes qui peuvent partir ah il y a
un gain direct ok
ouais facile en
fait en fait il veut faire l'ordi il y a
pas cavalier F4 pour le moment à cause
de dame prend E5 et donc l'ordi commence
par A4 chasse la dame de cette rang4
après cavalier F4 et du coup on joue sur
la découverte et euh dame B3 K5 4 dame
B3
k pas très dur pas très
dur bah en fait tu as tellement envie de
faire une découverte que tu regardes
tout ce que tu peux faire ta gauche al
après le problme c'est qu' est peut-être
sur du f F6 ou d'autres
trucs mais en soi
ouais parti ouais c'est horrible au
final
mais avec des rebondissements
ouais mais tuis signalé qualité de l'IR
détérioré
là tu es revenu bien mais peut-être ils
ont souffert
ouais il s'est
raté la partie de relativement mauvaise
ité avec beaucoup de gaffe de de part et
d'autres apparemment à vérifier après
avec un ordi plus fort non mais la 4
c'est sûr que ça
gagne mais ouais en fait le truc c'est
qu'il l'IT pas du tout quoi enfin que je
te disais peut-être qu'il regarde F pr
F6 et que il pe autre
chose mais bon là en fait ça a l'air
léger l'attaque quand même tu as quoi tu
as une tour moins contre trois pions
mais le problème c'est que ouais si le
fou qui revient en C3 il va tout couvrir
quoi quand tu vas revenir en G7 en fait
c'est facile en plus s C3 faire sans
rien calculer en fait
ouais très mauvais match de Maxim au
final ouais ouais
étonnamment bon après écoute s' arri à
le faire tomber on va voir mais là bon
la position est vraiment plutôt
foutue c'est pas son habitude de rater
tu es des coups comme à 4 quand même
même si je suis d'accord avec toi
c'était pas facile ah mais on parle
quand même de mvl hein ouais bah c'est
pas non plus super dur enfin je veux
dire genre perso je m'en voudrais de pas
l'avoir vu
quoi donc euh moi
aussi mais bon après c'est du rapide les
parties s'enchaîne enfin c'est TJ pareil
hein je pensis quand même plus voulu de
la partie d'avant
[Musique]
comparativement sa là je pense qu'il
veut c'est Dame prend F6 fou prend F6 on
pourrait penser qu'il a C
F4 mais je pense qu'il veut faire fou le
5 reprend le 6 prend F4
prends8 reprends et jouer ça non pour
être bien sûr de faire nul
ouais je sais pas
j'imagine ça je pensais qu'on prit F
C4 tu met l'autre je sais
pas il a des pass partout mais bon ouais
ça on sait pas enfin c'est un certain je
sais pas comment
juger les noir quand même parce que P on
passé éloigné doit être fort mais il a
pris à de pris ok pris à de ça fait
quoi c'est pas bête en fait il a le pion
qui avance il il pousse à fond quoi ok
euh écoute il a dû bien juger parce
qu'il a joué vite ce truc euh moi
j'avais l'autre avec ce fou 5 je
[Musique]
trouvais je jetais juste un œil au au
raté de
Maxime donc sement à 4 il va continuer
sa
route la FO F7 et surtour F6 il va
mettre le r en G7 ouais pas laisser fou
adverse revenir en C4 ce qui qui fera
vraiment un bon boulot en C4 mais il
peut pas il en F1 là-bas un peu couper
du du reste du monde un peu
grégoryi je sais pas si va faire tour au
7 ou à 3
mais toi ça bien tout garder sous
contrôle et malheureusement je crois que
c'est plus trop d'espoir
ouais comme tu dis Fab noir c'est noir
la J il n'y a plus
d'espoir partie étonnante ouais pas très
ouais pas une grande
partie
aprs c'est des coupes pas simples mais
après ouis avec la jauge on voit les
opportunités et le A4 non mais bien s
c'est toujours plus facile quand on te
dit il y a un truc à chercher tu es
gagnant cherche tu
trouve que quand tu es tout seul dans
unchig tu ser rien et que
bon ah bah oui
donc juste on peut être frustré quand on
combine la partie d'avant et est raté
ici
ouis c'est un match qui va être perdu
qui aurait
lre4 pr C4
G6 problème c'est queon pourra faire C4
un meilleur moment et après
filer jusqu'à dame trop du bonheur pour
ce
P mais ça va un peu hipothéquer les
chances de Maxime pour un top 2 à mon
avis h
ouais F 7 ou fou je sais pas où
ouais il se bat quand même quoi il se
joue des petits coup il peut y avoir des
réseaux de mat je en train de penser à
ça je suis en train de me dire il peut y
avoir des réseaux de mat tour F7 et tu
sais pas bah si t F7 3 H8 qui G6 ro G8
mat to F7 du coup tu vas faire ro pr H6
qui
F5 G66 mais oui mais bon te bat un peu
quoi tu plus te battre beaucoup quand
même tuespère faire une enfilade un truc
un
moment bon tour à 2 ça être chiant dame
1 pour tour à
1 il encore 3 minutes c'est encore
beaucoup
coup t 8 pas mal
aussi point exclamation pour rest ave
sur H7 mais je crois pas que ça change
grand chose c'est le coup le plus dur
qu'il eu à trouver dans sa
carrière
c'est bon Maxime quand
même il a encore une nul quoi
il est tellement heureux de te laisser
nul
quoi une dame d'avance n'intéresse pas
du tout
quoi va vim faire
F5 c'est beau en fait tu encore nul mais
tu peux pas prendre quoi ou ça même
donné
quoi non c'est une faute
de
maisc par qu'il a changé de case
je penses qu'il était vraiment ven en F7
de base
avec ça te met en confiance de VO peut
prendre ça ouis
bah je demande si çais pas justeend F5
un moment
donné oui il change sa dame tout le
temps
enfin sonts tout seul
ou ça me
fracasse se met en PLS avec une dame de
plus qu ouais il veut tellement que
Maxime lu répète les cou que mais
regarde il est en train le mat en fait
juste
max
cont mais regarde s
[Musique]
vraent il va
faire mais c'est fou comment il se c'est
j'ai rarement vu ça à ce niveau il peut
tomber force de faire
conire coup c
faire t
f76 prend cheval
ahire d d mais la partie elle est
incroyable il a
trouvé7 il l' content pour F
regarde c'estou il a faill perdre ça
quoi
est-ce que Maxime va pouvoir trouver
quelque
chose il a fait
G4
bonentôt moins de minute qu pour ça dame
G6 H4 dame
B6
problme c'est que G g
après F2 même en
fait il toujours avoir
G5 il veut faire tour
D6 alors pas des
[Musique]
damesux pas
va tour D3 pour repartir par
là-bas je crois que c'est plus une
seconde à partir du 60e ah oui ah oui tu
peux plus tomber alors
maintenant tu peux faire tour des6 tu
refais le truc de tout à l'URE ah mais
il va faire dame prendre des6 et la
finale elle va ah mais quoi ok pr prend
F4 et
Machin fait E5
c'est extraordinaire pls le pauvre là
quoi j'ai l'ession qu'il pourrait même
canner de peur quoi t C7 c'est chelou il
tour D6 il veut tour ouais mais tour C6
tour D7 c'est bizarre je pense pas il va
bouger sa dame c'est tout mais tour en
C7 je la trouve mal placée je sais pas
trop comment
dire
je sais pas la partie est tellement
bizarreo que j'ai l'impression que tout
peut arriver encore
quoi en vrai j'ai jamais vu ça j'ai
vraiment jamais vu
ça j'ai ça arrive que à des gens comme
nous
ouais de faire de la merde comme çaar
plus ENF moi ça m'arrive tu t'attends
pas à top mondial qui se mettent autant
au
pls
c'est bien jou max fa G5
pour amener la tour en G6 entre
guillemets4 je
regard prend G6 prendre le
cavalier après c'est vraiment
nul bouger son roi quoi assz
vite
ah en plus il d C6 il va faire dame G6
non ça il devrait quand même parater
maintenant petite fourchette un moment
quo ouais je sais pas c'est toujours pas
fini quoi ça me bute
quoi
Maxime c'est bien en fait les coup comme
3 c'est pas
mal ah mince cette fois-ci j'ai
bloqué prend
terrible ça aura
ché serassé pour gagner qu'une dame de
plus et dans l'autre partie on va mettre
juste les Chiquet parce qu'on aura pas
le temps de de tout switch donc abdorof
avec les Blancs qui doit gagner mais qui
a une position sympa quand même les nons
sont à l'envers mesdames et
messieurs mais
oui
c'est un partout le score dans ce match
c'est bien joué qu'il fait ve tour à 3
tour
B3 sur 4 il va passer de l'autre côté il
veut tour à 8 tour B8 t pr B2
B1 bien jou çaêre
abandon du coup
[Musique]
enOn qui qui son compteur du coup qui
son compteur et la zavic bah qui reste
bon dernier t
seul scotché à cette dernière place
après trois matchs et donc ensuite nous
allons avoir les matchs mvel lazavic
justement ah Sophi Rouja Carlsen
Nakamura et abdusatorov carwana on se
retrouve dans une petite demi-heure je
crois Fab à peu près on surveilla du
coin de l'œil on vous dira on n pas
encore sur cette pause là on n'est pas
on n pas sûr moi je regarde en fait le
live en anglais donc n'hésitez pas à
regarder le live officiel ils ont
beaucoup d'informations en fait sur
place forcément oui euh qu'on a qu'on
peut pas avoir tout simplement parce que
c'est c'est en direct aux États-Unis ils
ont des infos de Toronto donc n'hésitez
pas aller sur la page chess nous-même en
fait on regarde la page chess en en
anglais donc n'hésitez pas à aller aller
jeter un coup d'œil
pendant que nous ne sommes pas là et euh
et comme ça on regardera le même contenu
on aura les mêmes informations et on
tiendra à jour ceux qui l'ont pas fait
merci à tous à tout de suite donc pour
pour les matchs des Français et le
classico
[Musique]
carura c m them ins with magnet and swap
themever you make your exclusive
discount on all metal posters shop now
with the code ch
[Musique]
displate.com
les amis on est de de retour avec le Fab
ouais et on sait pas encore encore
exactement où sont les câes mais on va
vous mettre ça à jour dès que dès que
possible ça devrait bientôt repartir on
nous a dit vers 45 mis en place des
joueurs donc on arrive à
43 pas non plus largement en avance mais
on sait pas trop quoi vous dire non plus
on va pas se
mentir donc on attend on attend pour le
moment alors que là on a un
fig
alors
Mach Magus
ou peti Siest
réparatrice
re c'est ça qu'on de regarder tu penses
ouais pourquoi pas ouais ça pe être
sympa vous en pensez quoi l'équipe PZ
nous
dire Maxime il joue contre laavic bon
regarder mais et joue Wesley oua VI de
le voir franchement non il en a Mar
Westley en vrai il en a marre
l'équipe jeir le
chat
c'est encore des gens dans le chat parce
qu'il y a une belle pause là ah
ouais c'est pour mieataquer mais en fait
je suis d'accord avec toi ça change un
peu on regarde tout le temps les
Français
là mais bon un petit classico puis M
laav c'est pas trop le match cool en
fait non mais
euh
ah il y a le Tess à Rama
euh c'est leche qui joue au foot là tout
ça ça c'est vra
extraordinaire
toi penser on est pas bien ouais
marlou est-ce que si tu étais sur place
tu aurais lancé un chalala
marlou est-ce que vous aimez bien quand
il y a du publicque d'ailleurs dans la
salle du coup vous préférez
quand quand c'est plus classique et
quand c'est full silencieux tiens on va
demander on en profite on discute un
tout petit peu après on a une minute de
décalage donc on on aura pas le temps de
rebondir sur vos réponses mais donc la
question est simple est-ce que vous
préférez les échecs comme ça un peu
feutrés où les joueurs peuvent bien se
concentrer comme il faut quand même
c'est important ou est-ce que vous
préférez un truc un peu plus festif ou
où on est plus là pour s'amuser
peut-être un peu au détriment du niveau
de jeu quoi que pas forcément même B des
fois des fois ça boêtre très feutré le
niveau est pas toujours là heinir des
erreurs ici ou là allez c'est parti des
des5 c'est4 c'est 5 ah ouais ça c'est
rare non c'est très rare
je pensais qu'on faisait pion prend D5
dame prend D5 qui F3 c'est prend D4 qui
C3 on va
voir de scandinave quoi ouais ça peut te
plaire quoi du coup non je suis très
heureux maintenant j'ai envie de le
jouer quoi je suis
là non mais en gros tu vas avir
normalement une une sorte de de de
structure symétrique hein parce que ds
vont s'échanger tu vas être un peu mieux
développé quand même avec les
Blancs moi j'iris sur k F3 CD en s'il
fait CD je sais pas et et k C3 en tout
cas c'est ce qu'il
fait
je prends du cavalier tiens voilà
peut-être PASC G3 ou
quoi l' de tout connaître par cœur
quoi je suis en train de me dire enfin
moi j'y pense pour moi en fait je oui
bon c'est mes positions en fait j'ai une
dame 5 je suis tellement
heureux bah je suis là quoi ah tu es
là 5 il faut H3
après il faut plutôt demander laave des
joueurs euh moi je pars toujours du
principe que quand tu fais un sport une
compétition la vie des joueurs il est
important mais il est pas
prioritaire évidemment il est important
parce qu'ils doivent pouvoir jouer mais
pas juste pour vous dire nous hier quand
on est un peu sorti avec les joueurs
après c'est pas qu'ils ont ont kiffé
c'est qu'ils ont surkiffé en fait eux
ils préfèrent là pour le coup euh pour
ce qu'on a fait hier c'est sûr que les
joueurs il
préférai et les caméras non synchro ça
rend dingue ouais alors là je pense que
elles sont synchro sur la prod aux
États-Unis mais c'est normal comme nous
on n'est pas aux États-Unis et qu'on a
une autre prod du coup c'est normal que
ce soit ce serait c'est très dur de
synchroniser voire impossible
malheureusement
je pense qu'il connaît car l'air de
jouer vite visement quand Mme un peu
mieux au blanc
tu un peu mieux ou tu faire fou5 tour
c1ah je dire ça serait trop
simple faire des 4 D5 4 C5 c'est égalisé
en force quoi serait
beau joue la symétrie complète
quoi
jou
5 je pense qu'il connaît
encore mais il joue vite en tout cas
mais oui tu as l'impression que tu es un
peu mieux ouais fou G5 t C1 fou G5
peut-être des fois des fou pr F6 pour
mettre l'autre Caval en D5 à
voir
ça le but il en fait vraiment des C car
regarde la vidéo c'est
[Musique]
S réfléch cé
Magnus il ok bon coup
normal il dev ouais il devait se décider
entre rock d'abord ou fou
G5
ok fautussst tempo qui a des 5
ok l'ordim pas mais c'est hyper logique
hein il se sait filmer mais je sais pas
si carou il est pas même comme ça quand
il est seul chez lui
quoi sous sa
douche c'est quelqu'un que j'aimais bien
rencontrer quand
mêmeo j'aais bien d avec lui pour voir
un peu je sais pas parit vraimentis car
j'en ai absolument rien à faire de le
connaître ou pas c'est quelqu'un qui
m'intéresse absolument pas g tu es
curieux car je suis curieux premier
degré c'est quelqu'un que j'aimerais
bien rencontrer enfin rencontrer je dire
just mon mais genre si on me demandait
quel joueur de haut niveau tu aimerais
bien j'a bien rencontrer ikarou et Guiri
le i le double i non mais je pense ces
deux personnes en fait soit ils sont
complètement
cons soit ils sont hyper intéressants
mais en fait je pense c'est pas au
milieu car j'aimerais VO tuas une chance
qui soit très intéressant il a une
chance qui soit vraiment intéressant AR
rogant intéressant
ouais c'est vrai mais bon on peut
marlou cramnick interesting ouais ver
interesting non cramnick c'est sûr c'est
interesting mais
bon et
ding ding j'aurais du mal à communiquer
avec lui is tu sens que tu passes un
repas à te regarder bon tu manges quoi
enfin tu fais des bons met de qualité
mais les carou j'aimerais bien le
rencontrer après ça peut être un
on a brutx quoi aussi enfin non mais
tuen s rien il y a le risque aussi mais
je pense qu'il
pourrait et NPO NPO je connais un petit
peu il est assez lo je trouve assez
drôle mais après les gens l'aiment pas
trop
généralement tu sais ce qu'il m'a
dit en tout cas le coup de Carlson
mérite de d'avoir sortiout ses
connaissances
c'est pas le coup de l'ordi hein ouais
mais donc on s'attend je pas ouais donc
F prend des 5 à priori puis on prend et
T et kakin kakin je connais aussi il est
absolument
inintéressant
et h h moi c'est pas trop ma tasse de
thé
après il a le droit d'exister
hein
Maxim est bien ouais Maxime on pense
qu'il va gagner contre la zavi
normalement il est bien favori du match
après
bon on peut TJ louper une partie quelque
chose ça arrive mais bon
normalement
c'est un match ouais est censé gagner on
va dire
ouais bon Maxime je juste comme ça ça
joue c'est une c'est une la finale
debinoise
qu' a déjà des résultats non non ça joue
il y a pas de petites
nul mais qui rchit beaucoup quand
même il a vraiment plongé dans le
truc qu' avec autre chose les prend et T
ou je sais
pas parce que bon F prend ça l' logique
tu as pas envie de rebouger la dame en
tout cas donc c'est fou prend cavalier
prend mais je s du
tout
alors
leationation c'est censé être une erreur
mais bon c'est une erreur d'après la
turb
[Musique]
nette pas viment de mauvais
coup
numéro4 pour défendre ce pion de être
possible
j' plus ver F3 moi aussi je su enain de
me demander si on pouit un jour prendre
C6 donner la dame et essayer mais en
fait je pens à ça si oui grand rock
ouais ah enfin je ve dire s'il av pris
du cavalier des5 ouais
grand ouais je sais j'avais la même
ligne que toi ouais et sil faisait tour
tu prends le fou et F7 et PE je sais pas
ce que ça donne mais la même
je sais pas ce que ça don mais je
l'aurais fait et Carlson des fois il
aime bien donner la dame genre contre
Maxime là contre qu Maxime il l'a battu
d'ailleurs mais
ouais gen de sacrifice qui peut le
l'intéresser
F3 pas mal
jouer 4 je pas t moi je connaissais sur
ouais mieux que par
tour
tour D5 tour 4 je voulais
faire tu es plus
for mais c'est peut-être
mieux
après calculer
F5
pas F5 est-ce qu'on
joue
fait pas t on fait
de
exact
tour d'abord pourquoi
pas
il attaque la
tour
ouais c'est pas mal ça va l'aider ça de
le
développement bizarre de pas avoir fait
direct moi tour 1 mais j'avais pas fou
B4 donc c'est vrai que quand tu as fou
B4 tu dis en fait
ça
ça été raté par
Magnus
après juste fou des deux mais bon les
noir ça va ça peut juste simplifier
assez vite si c'est comme
ça ça pas l'air grave pour Magnus ce qui
se passe mais s un moment les noir ro E4
et tr contre
D5 ça va devenir vite très très
symétrique et s'il y a plus de paire de
fou au moins pour qui soit un avantage
ben tranquille il fait une bonne partie
hein
on peut faire T 4 alors peut-être ouais
je me
questionnais en tout cas ça se
regarde peêre y avoir 4 4 pr 4 prend h
prend H5 prend mais je pense ce sera pas
assz
pas le petit fou des deux
hm
hm bon sûrement faut prendre le4 prends
le4 tu reprends 4 tu reprends
D5 ça peut vite faire nul tout
ça tu jouis Micha euh non
ça alors il a pris B4
d'abord VO cavalier prend ouais ça va
tout
liquider s'énerve
ais désolé on a notre chien qui s'énerve
de cette
nul par il se sera pas passé grandchose
Fab non mais du
coup voilà mais tu vas pouir la tester
dans tes blits
et j'espère bien Fab et carou ouais CIT
une bonne petite
[Musique]
idéeemployé
ouais bien égalisé
quoi après bon Magnus est capable
d'essayer de te la jouer s'il peut
sauver le fou
mais TR ce qu'on peut faire et Maxime tu
peux nous dire un petit point téléphone
ouais vas-y
je ça on a pas besoin de tout
traficoter finale de la berinoise
a peut-être pas grand-chose ouais un
poil mieux mais
ou Maxime c'est comme ça euh Wesley
contre
fou c'est le combat c'est le combat gen
C italiennes compliqué euh et il y a
nordibbec contre Fabiano
[Musique]
euh il y a pas de décision faite ça joue
ça
F on a la partie un peu bon c de Max non
plus pas M anim de less anim mais bon ok
il il cons le fou mais pas pour longts
priori ça devrait faire nul assz
vite F3 ça prend pas fait un
petit de la
tête
ouis est-ce que bon sais rien mais je me
demande estce qu'ils ont des des
consigne sur le pas nul avant je sais
pas quoi ou je sais
pas je j'imagine au moins jusqu'au 30e
ouais maintenant c'est quand même la
norme
he mais en fait je pense c'est faut
enlever la proposition de nul aux
échecs moi je seraaiis dégoûté bon je ne
jai plus mais mais en soi il y a pas pas
de raison
quoi la position elle est bien bien
égale par contre rarou je ser en train
de suer hein quand
même contre mec ça va c'est ça
êre Magnus c'est
l'avantage
je pense qu'ikaro il peut vouloir jouer
pour le gain il est symboliquement
peut-être mieux non je suis pas sûr
qu'il saute sur la nulle mais tu peux
pas faire grand chose quand même
là reste plus trop de pièce
quo
ouais un petit tour des C
peut-être qui va monter en puissance
hein les amis de jour en jour puis nous
aussi à vrai dire on récupère un petit
peu he moi depuis quelques semaines là
il y avait beaucoup de de taf et je dois
dire
que CIT le point culminant c le point
culminant et là du coup euh il a joué à
4re euh euh ok c'est 5 j'imagine voilà
c'est fait c'est une fourchette ça quand
même al tu peux faire B5 sur tout
défendre mais on naime pas trop avcer
les pions comme ça parce que bon on se
les
affaibli c'est que j'aurais préféré
visuellement après j'ai rien calculé
mais ton tour des5 au coup d'avant que
cétait pour contôer le faire ça la tour
de de cas en diagonal cavalier c'est
hyper bien placé tu le focalises ouais
tu le tu savais
je crois qu'on en a parlé dans le dans
l'
ouais c'est beau quoi je
crois on sait même plus ce qu'on sait
quoi
[Musique]
mais dans dans la même rubrique a il y a
le fou B tout le monde connaît à trois
cases le roi et la tour je crois petits
diagrammes
TR cas du cavalier c'est
bien de cases du coup oui de cas en
diagonale positionition
diagonale j'ai TR
cases et la tour en E par rapport au
cavalier F5 aussi à côté sinon cavalier
en F5 la tour6 défend
bien truc de
Vlade
pression qu' remonte ouais
c'était beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de de
boulot et beaucoup de
pression qui m'a vu avant a vu à quel
point j'étais
stressé prendre la tour se planter en B4
et faire
nul ça on
aime sympa cette petite nul parti de
qualité propre
propre on demande où ça se joue ça se
joue à Toronto
actuellement
ça tout
échangé faire nul tu peux nous dire truc
intéressant aur
ouais alors je Maxime bon ça tourne il
va essayer mais bon pas gagné
al compliqué je sais pas trop trop
compliqué et c le bordel toujour l'être
attends
[Musique]
pourquoi je pas mais le truc fait
n'importe
quoi cou Tom
mal comme ça faire nul on va on va
changer de
Maxime ça a fait nul on va aller voir al
tout bêtement
ouais ils ont fait
nul serrer la main à la
caméra et donc qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il
la il a de Tours contre la
dame en train de mettre
les
c'est bien c'est ce qui a les
blanc mais parti importante non pour Al
res il doit pas être bien au classement
non un point classementess de de cette
partie le classement surscom n'est pas
correct he spik SP en
twitch
position pas claire je sais pas trop pr
tendance à préf les tours si j'arrive à
les connecter et à faire des choses mais
sa on disc avec B a pas si longtemps en
fait maintenant avec Alpha 0 ils ont
vraiment renforcé la p de la dame
ah la dame est
devenue pas forcément plus forte mais on
on l' sous-estimé un petit peu
quoi le truc c'est que est-ce qu'on sait
la l'utiliser
quoi que l'ordi te dise en fait c'est
mieux et si et ça bon ben très bien mais
et concrètement comment ça se passe
quoi alle en mode beau gosse ouais en
mode kimono mod kimono
ouais yo le
a
alors que Magnus nous gêne pour voir les
caméras il y a pas de il y a pas de
spectateurs mais il réussissent quand
même à avoir
des la
gène B on prend2 je sais
pas
il
[Musique]
Hite
blo mais ça m'
pas non plus
plus fait tu contreat le
[Musique]
cavalier tu prends le 7 maintenant
peut-être dommage je rater dame B3 quand
même hein mais attends mais dame B3
repri prend F2 c'était quoi la suite il
peut-être prendre à 4 bêtement h alors
il nous fait G4 il va affaiblir un peu
le pion 4 euh ben écoute on va voir je
sais pas il peut se passer plein de
choses en fait dans la position elle est
compliqué
ouais ça me fait un peu peur pour les nm
quand même je sais pas puis on prend G4
qui est D5 truc c'est moi qui fait peur
c'est qu' il joue maintenant tout le
temps des positions comme ça sauf
qu'avant il est gagné très souvent
mainant il est perd tout le
temps ça reste compliqué
il mais
ouais mais il a pas le temps en plus il
a 15 secondes
ouis ah non il su al
globalement je pense c'est un peu un
genre de r en fait comme
Mamé
je pense s récupère r il peut de
nouveau relancer la machine mettre une
pièce dans le du box
ouais B tuas histoire de confiance
aussire sont importantes tu dois
enclencher des des
ressorts positifs ou
négatifs il men par aurait plus cal
échec
s tour qui
attaquer5 pour protéger j'aime pas trop4
qui va
arriver attaque des trucs à droite à
gauche as peut-être AR jouer
voil tempo logique auss peut prendre H4
4 H5 et pouss le pion ou
quoi
mieux que d'avoir pris au 4 ça menace
une
fourchette pr C4 il attaque la tour il
attaque le pion E4 cal C3 ah non mais il
est bloqué à la défense de la case
F4 je me questionnais il y a de
coup quand il 6 si on pouvait pas juste
ramener la tour de D7 en D24 fourchette
et jouer avec tour cavalier contre la
dame à tout moment on
pouvait je CIS qu'il va la tenir
finalement parce je pense qu'il y a
juste un PERP per
PERP en plus comme une tour non
protégant D7 à plein de de
rebondas plein d'endroit où tu peux pas
vraiment de truc que tu peux pas
vraiment faire quoi
pas perpè tout de suite qu' garde les
pièces sur les
chiquers j'imagine pas trop les blancs
en mesure de gagner mais
bon il tente en tout cas hm hm peut-être
aussi parce qu'il a un avantage aant en
fait si westler va doubler les tours sur
la colonne F c'est chiant parce qu'il va
prendre F4 il va prendre
F6 donc il a bon il y a ce projet là on
va
dire projet lo parce que sur tour C2
pour tour C3 il y avait dame 4 et tu
tour F3 il y a dame pr C2
il t train du tout là bah peut même se
retrouver se retourner contre lui
hein d' il a plus le temps à son
tour il pas tour2 à cause de
F3 F3 prend2 donc il y a des petits
pièges à gauche à droite et là l'ordi
donne complètement gagnant après F5
c'est
raté alors est-ce que l'ordi raconte
nimp peut-être pas parce que en fait F5
du coup après tu fais dame prend enfin
ro prend et peut-être tu
rentres
dommage d'avoir raté mais bon il avait
plus de
temps mais il a l'air de regarder les
yeux r sur la position
ouis c'est H5 c'est pas facile
parce qu'près tu rentres B tu ouis mais
bon ok enfin c'est oui c'est pas facile
peutêtre tu F3 là ouais pour all
mat raté mais tu vois ça quand on parle
de confiance on va juste aller voir les
Chiki en gardant ces ces joueurs là
c'est caroana Kana qui P de moin avec
les
Noirs comme position je sais pas euh
ouais logique ce qui
fait on pe se mettre en B 3 2 làbas et
avancer B
après il a dû jouer à un Fabi
là il a un petit problème de
ouais GT la caméra
peut-être c'est pas ces joueurs là
euh enfin c'est pas leur nom c'est ouis
c'est le N ouais c'est c'est bien eux
mais c'est pas leur nom
voilà je crois qu'il y a eu un truc avec
avec le
la C il a joué f5a il l'avait
vu mais pourquoi il va pas juste jouer à
tour D3 et puis tour B2
et tour B3 moi je sais pas
enfin il essaie de ramener son roi petit
à
petit il va faire W F4 ouais pour
essayer de
bloquer4 qui de l'ordi qui est logique
il a fait4
F5 l' de suer complètement Abdou
c'est peut-être pas simple à gagner
hein B2 je comprend mais t B3 je pars
par
[Musique]
là-bas je sais pas en fait je suis en
train de me
questionner non mais je vois le problème
enfin ouais en fait tour B3 ro F5 tour 2
il va te faire tour G1 tu dis moi je
fais roi F2 l'autre tour en F1 et sur R
3 tu trs une en fil
h et que peut-être tu as du mal
à qu'il y a des coups qui sont joués
mais que les Chiquet su pas du tout non
rien et on n pas une crème grand angle
euh
[Musique]
ouais mais on va pas voir non trop loin
c'est dommage on aura pu avoir un une
caméra peut-être vue aérienne ouais
ouais au-dessus quoi çait pas mal ça
pouvait déranger les joueurs Fab
peut-être HM d'avoir une cam du dessus
je su en train de regarder s'ils ont sur
la chaîne US je comprend pourquoi ils
l'ont pas fait parce que si ça ça les
Jeurs il vaut mieux
pr de bruit la camé ou en plus ça fait
bruit les caméras comme tu dis vaut
mieux privilégier le jeu au spectacle à
mon avis la qualité de
jeu h45 le truc c'est que le roi il
repart dans le bon
côté si le Rove à se mettre entre les
pions là-bas il va vraiment les bloquer
un peu gâché
Abdou de plus ça peut quand même bien
passer pour lui mais américains qui on
une autre cam qui un peu plusou un pe
m que vous
recommander pas en fait ils ont mis la
cam comme ça compris
ils ont fini ou non ça échange des trucs
ils ont fini je crois ouais ah ben il a
gagné on sait pas trop comment s'est
passé mais il a gagné voilà mais il a
gagné il s'est fait
ouais il s'est pris une série d'échec en
fait et ouis ilut Perre sa tour ou s
remter
même ok donc on a les les résultats
victoire d'absatorov contre caroana nul
dans la partie de Carlsen contre raro
nul dans la partie de so contre firouja
et une partie de Melle contre lazavi on
se retrouve dans une petite dizaine de
minutes pour la suite mesdames et
messieurs merci à tous et à très vite
dans une petite dizaine de
minutes but neither would a Sicilian
defense to the untrained eye this is a
performance enhancer you don't see it
how about now manage your air quality
sharpen your performance change the game
with air things a new opening for your
wall is here capture new major pieces on
unique metal posters from displate now
with the official collection from
Chess.com Mount them ins with a toolf
magnet kit and swap them whenever you
like make your move get an exclusive
discount on all metal posters shop now
with the code chess
[Musique]
displate.com
et allez on va être reparti les amis
pour pour la fin alors on va pas aller
voir ça on va pas aller voir Maxime
contre laavic on fait on va aller voir
magnou magnou
Carlsen c'est
ici
contre contre Nakamura
donc désolé je galéris un peu à trouver
comment mettre les noms au bon endroit
et je me disais qu'il fallait mettre
aussi à jour le score
Fab
05 05 mais bon 000 ça marcherait aussi
en fait ou les gens comprenne qu'il a
une première
partie est-ce qu'on pourrait faire un
point classement peut-être ouais attends
je vais mettre ça à jour
Fab
donc je voulais faire un point
classement si je comprends bien
ok donc on voit que pour le moment c'est
Caren et qui caracole en
tête et Maxime un peu dans le ventre mou
là il va avoir du mal à
finir le top 2 top 2 ouais mais il
faudra pas faire top 7
non fa éviter de dernières plac
quoi c'est pas
fait c'est parti qui vient entamer par
des4 parti
retour 15+ la cadence toujours la
même
bon plutôt pour jouer ça maintenant que
prend F6
j'aipr
[Musique]
qui mais j'ai joué comme ça du coup il
jou d'abord ça change quelques petits
truc
ouais donc c'est une position avec les
noir on va priori avoir un P isolé
vraiment la paire de
fou qui aide à compenser mais bon c'est
plutôt solide en fait côté noir les
blanc qui vont vouloir mettre la
pression sur D5 en faitin s'ils peuvent
ouais mett un fou en G2 un cavalier F4
un cavalier en C3 il mange le pion mais
évidemment c'est un doux rêve
hein F 6 donc il vient renforcer
des5
K 2 bon jeends k
C6 2 c'est dans le plan he qu'on a
énoncé plus
tôt
génial invité dans les grands événements
là il est pas invité il s'est qualifi
comme comme tous les autres d'ailleurs
il a pas d'invitation
là petre CD F
B4
PR4 c'est solide en fait plus aprè la
case 5 pour sauter avec le cavalier bon
des trucs et si c'est CD alors tu auras
beaucoup moins de problèmes sur D5 quoi
quand même en avoir oui oui mais bon
déjà une colonne en moin quoi pour se
faire attaquer dessus le temps de faire
fou D6 et sur fou 7 un truc comme
ça à
voir mais oui sur CD je prendrais plutôt
de avec les Blancs que du
cavalier que du cavalier
F B4 je pense qu' est
chiant il la machine qui joue depuis une
semaine bah tu peux aller tu peux aller
sur ma chaîne youtube point
d'exclamation non pas de pointexation
facile mais tu tapes blit stream facile
sur sur Youtube tu auras plein de vidéos
pour t'aider
ouais très bien
faite
qui a pris du cavalier ok je pensais que
F B4 était un peu chiant mais
bon on va voir ce qui joue mais oui ça a
l'air
pénible
le fou qui vient clouer ce cavalier et
puis mettre une pression sur C3
éventuellement avec tour C8 là t C8 ou
quoi qui peut
arriver peut-être tour C8 maintenant
cavali 5 je sais pas au rock coup
hein re tour
direct j'aurais fait tour direct
personnellement moi aussi ou mais après
sur A3 pr C3 tu as rien du coup c'est
pas très intéressant je prend qu éche
ou pour ça que je
dis
après tu vas faire FO
5 il y a trop de Dam 5 aussi ouais il y
a peut-être d 5 aussi j'ai B3 prend C3
ouais
ça pas l'air simple à jouer pour les
blancs
h non c'est PL une bonne ligne avec les
n
ouais
Vlad savait déjà longtemps ah il y a
très longtemps qui sa m' demandé de
regarder ça pour
lui quand on était en Islande avec
l'équipe de France quoi en je plus Ctait
2015 ou quoi mais c'est en fait mais
déjà sil me demande donc c'est qui c'est
enfin c'est pas moi qui lui trouvé c'est
lui m'a dit ça
[Musique]
donc
complexe pour
ikarou bon après il est pas encore trop
mal mais effectivement tu as pas
d'avantage avec les blancs en tout cas
il est pas mettre en difficulté son
adversaire il faire attentionce que ça
tourne pas mal ouis ça tourne
mal6 c'est peut-être un fou
B5 fou B5 mais bon si tu fais baisser et
que tu remets ta structure tu as juste
la paire de fou là ouais et tu peux
pousser des pions les LO en plus ouis
comme tu en as
beaucoup
fiasco faut des 6 à l'air logique on
repart et après euh tu fais petit rock
tu peux faire F5 même G5 tu pourras
faire tout ton fou F4 pour aller ouvrir
et bon après car on sait hein c'est un
bon défenseur
mais bon sonou sous pression après 10
coup avec les Blancs on n aaime jamais
ça non ce truc que là c'est pression à
long terme h il c'est pas trois coups
préis à trouver c'est faud être bon
pendant un bon petit
moment
complexe Stre dure combien de temps
encore environ je pense encore 1 heure
et demi et PP qui dit une force de la
nature avec la backup tuenchaîne respect
ouais enfin là on fait pas non plus avec
Fab notre meilleur stream
de la décennie on a on suit un peu là
quand même là là c'est ça se sent on est
mou on est mou ou je peux pas même pas
utiliser ma voix pour habituellement
j'utilise ma voix pour masquer quand je
suis mou mais là je peux même pas le
faire je peux pas plus forcer dessus là
je suis au
maximum si je fais plus je je me détruis
la
gorge chaque jour qui va passer on
va bien pour les demifinales dans 3 4
jours
là malheureusement j'ai de la chance
d'avoir une voix qui me sert à faire
illusion parfois mais là vous voyez sans
mon ma botte
secrète et j'ai pas
Ana on pas an de bot du tout du coup
c'est notre
botte toujours de l'énergie an mais là
je crois qu'elle aussi elle est KO ou je
crois qu'on est tous bien
fatigués toutes nos bottes secrètes on
été utilis c'est un peu comme dans les
je on est pi nul on a mis tous nos bonus
quoi on
su al d B6 attaque
[Musique]
B2 est-ce que même Sébastien est épuisé
Mao
ouais je l'ai pas demandé mais je pense
que oui si même Mazo est fatigué oua
c'est si même Mazo est
fatigué bon en gros sement il va faire
truc comme C3 fou G2 petit rock et
blinder comme il peut mais
c'est c'est un peu dégueu pour les
blancs tout ça
ouais ça su fort hein ouais mais bon
Magnus qui fait quand même un gros début
de tournoi qui 3 sur TR déjà et puis bah
là
il il met la pression avec les noir quoi
ah il a fait B3 passé 3 ok il défend le
pion comme ça petit
rock fou
G2 et maintenant Magnus de voir comment
il veut avancer ses pions est-ce qu'il
joue pour essayer de faire F5 F4 bon
pe-être pas si facile mais est-ce qu'il
va essayer est-ce qu'il va essayer de
faire C5 plutôt C5 D4 c'est c'est joli
si on y
arrive il joue t fd8 il se
centralise petit rock et donc peut-être
C5
5 ouais c'est très bien joué mais très
logique
après c'est pas difficile mais bon après
faut juste bien le réaliser dans le bon
tempo et et qu' a pas une peau de banane
qui t'empêche en fait mais priori il y
en a pas pour l'instant c'est logique et
donc après est-ce qu'il va essayer de
faire à 5 est-ce que il se met en place
[Musique]
quoi
a car qui qui agité sur sa chaise c'est
pas le Ikar qui qui danse là
que
non un point AC de gens qui on point pas
bien mais bon
après finisse mieux que ce
[Musique]
qu'ilent
maim la prière qui est
arriv
contre
contre donc il se bat quoi
je sais pas s'il va faire un zé pointé
dans le tournoi
quoi je me fais un petit tour de stade
pour voir il do pas se passer grandchose
pour le moment
ouais c'est intéressant ce qu'il a
joué et
[Musique]
Fabi mais pas
facile
ok Magnus qui a joué à 4 à 5 pardon donc
pour probablement essayer de jouer par
avec A4 plus tard je me demandais si les
blancs voulaient faire A4 eux même mais
je crois qu'il a pas trop envie deer
toutes les cases noires comme ça D4
jouer ESS de choper à
3 en fin de variante
peut-être
oh ça quand même peut-être aller pour
carou tout
ça il menace pas du tout mais je me dis
ed CD
DD4 est-ce que ça peut pas-être fous C5
son idée parce fait on doit échanger les
dames il Pr C on prend à 3 il prend le 6
ça ça court à la nulle assez vite non hm
je pense ouais donc
dcd dame prend D4
on aura un arme à gedon ah mais
peut-être qu'on l' aura quoi qu'il
[Musique]
arrive avec les
enchères je demande ouais qu'est-ce queo
mettrait comment cher pour avoir les
noirs
je sais pas mais peut-être se mettre 7
minutes 30 h a c'est dangereux contre
Magnus
hein une s de catalane pendant longtemps
tuas pas de temps il te presse il te
presse il te presse et
puis
alors il a pris de foond des quatre
comme
ça à tris
ici
bah c'est jouable quandme prend 3 non je
pense je
pense
il réfléchit en tout
cas ouais façon il compte reprendre à 3
va pas jouer P de moin après qui
intercal unou C5 C3 B3 est plus
faible des petits détails comme ça quoi
l'autre sûement récup à 3 qui traîne
pour rétablir l'équilibre matériel
bonsoir à Théodor dans le chat j'espère
que tu vas bien on a une minute de délai
he par contre donc un peu de retard sur
toi
ici
pas je explosé on te comprend Théodor on
te
comprend C55 va faire C3 il protège le
cavalier Batt il me dit après il prend à
3 en autant mais
bon
ai je vois qu'il aime bien fou G4 c'est
pas illogique après pr comme
nous qui demand C5
cétait jouable mais les blan C3 pour
renforcer le le
cavalier cétait jouable mais voilà bon
il a pris direct ça semblait bon juste
logique quoi et et on va
voir ça quand même solide pour les
blancs je veux dire
quand même cette paire de fou hein la
paire de
fou paire de fou position ouverte on
aime
bien
ouais c'est quand même mieux mais bon
après chose même F
C53 F6 j'avais pareil que prise
6 F et puis peut-être le pion peut
partir vers l'avant ouais ça doit être
égal mais peut-être un peu
chiant
de pion devant le roios favorise
l'attaque le pion s'est
passé est
tombéb pas ven jouer
[Musique]
quo je c'est juste que
c'est que je suis allé voir c'est pas
possible en
fait tell débile que
ouais ce chat nous surprendra toujours
F mais bon on va tout droit on va tout
droit vers vers l'armagedon là c'est
tant mieux Fab ça nous va faire un tout
petit peu plus de spectacle ce soir en
notre plus grand bonheur fa bien pour se
délecter
ouis
G6
oker remettre son fond C4 F6 il veut
tour F8
ouais fait bien de le
dire
nul signé pour Maxime on nous dit ok qui
va
aussiarmagedon on va se délecter des
Armagedon c'est génial on va en avoir
plusieurs en même
temps je pense on va rester sur ce match
a priori ouis ça sypa on pour zapper un
peu à droite à gauche ça va être
extraordinaire j'ai
hâte
on pouit avoir aussi une hule sur la
partie d'alliris on pourrait peut-être
avoir trois armesagéons de feu à suivre
en même temps F Fabi qui gagne qui
aussi alors là c'est Armagedon
général
ire en fait l'enu pour lui je pense
c'est tuas si tu tournes ce soir à qu
victoires il veut juste dans les de
premiers
puiss ouis en plus l'avantage c'est
qu'il y a quand même une belle pause
entre l'armag et le c'estêtre même TR qu
d'heure de plus donc c'est après on
savait qu' aura un Armagedon mais autant
en avoir un maximum en plus on va avoir
les super moment sur la chaîne chess la
chaîne
officielle avec avec les petits tableau
làardise ils ont le petit stylo ils
écrivent et là 1 2 3
ah 10
minutes c'est vraiment la la
trouvaille qui
perd c'est que so va
s'envoler
il est pas du tout tombé
alors ça va faire nul je pense qu'on
peut pe pe déjà zapper
pas du tout ça aucun rapport wou ils
sont tellement à côté dans le
chat pourquoi il serait perdant de
quoi chat non mais là j'ai un S que
oujour'hui sont particulièrement en
dessous le score c'est
enfin c'est 05 05 le score
ici moi j'aime bien les blancs en fait
mais bon tuas une qualité de
moi soit ça marche so ça marche
pas 08 quand même partie
serrée
mais du coup qui prend des 6 des TR
prend tu récupères
qualit est-ce que tu as vu le film Armon
ouais beau
film qui commence à dater un
peu
c'est nous qui
dat en vrai on date de
ouf je
sais toi un peu plus d'ailleurs ou
oui c'est qu'on date moi j'ai bienentô
40 ans là dans un mois dans un mois
ouais comme Sarah qu tu le S ça
date
[Musique]
s'appelle r comme ça ou
on y peut rien c'est
vrai je sais pas si en anglais SPP SAR
dat ah c'est bien joué ce F de j'y pensé
c'est clou ça coulera aussi pour enlever
la
dame
logique tu va faire Wesley dame D6
sûrement mais bon ils sert encore cloué
quand même DEES fite ah non il faut
H6 mais il fut prend
F3 tê de mes
fite SAR ça date ça fait longtemps qu'on
quoi qu'on l'a vu un peu rejouer que
nous on l'a pas vu mais c'est vrai
qu'elle a un peu rejoué SAR sa date
ouais VI en Espagne maintenant ou
Espagne maintenant ouais je CIS qu'elle
est dans le sud hein vers Malaga par
là-bas jolie
région
handalousie
ngas
spcho très très bel
endroit
complexe là pour Ali resa plus de 42
secondes B soit sa position ça doit
aller he mais il a quand même un P de
moins et euh ça peut mal tourner quoi du
coup et surtout j'ai l'impression que il
est chaud Wesley Wesley ouais
c'est TR matchs TR victoires c'est pas
mal quoi vu
l'opposition bon alors c'est pas la
bonne position j'imagine il jou oua
de coup
d'ffile
ok 6 probablement pour défendre un peu
le le pion
F6
ouais on peut la gagner celle-là ouais
tu sens qu'il peut aller pas loin d'être
mis pas lo d'être en
place
ira
ouais si tu tournes à une victoire tu as
un peu le se quand même tu es pas très
beau hein après il y a si places sur 8
donc
intéressant il a bien fait fait de faire
H4
ouais quier prend j'imagine qu'il veut
dam F6
G6 x
H6 essayer de mat en force
là-bas et du coup qu il prend H4 d prend
F6 faut sûrement jouer dame
4 mais euh bon qui menacera
mat c'est bien ça se met mal a temps
aussi
important dans la position là c'est
compliqué bien stabiliserutre aura sa
chance mais sinon il a
pris pr
F6 s
dessus sur B3 dame B1 sur F3 pardon
F3
jouer dans dame 2 ouais trouvable ou dam
B d'ailleurs les
deux il est hésitant8 et damage
4 bon ça devrait finir en nul tout ça
quand même même ouais ser finir en dame
1 dam H4 hein
ou si c pas les noirs qui le font qui
vont à la cuillette de B2 c'est les
blanc qui feront dame G4 et ouais on
devrait avoir un petit perpè dans les
prochain coup les deux joueurs quand les
deux joueurs peuvent faire perpè dans
les finales de dames c'est rarissime qu'
un joueur qui gagneut ne
F
ça va faire
nul donc on aura un autre Armon ici 3 et
Fabiano il fait
quoi connait pas trop ça P nul ou
là mais il va pas gagner va perdre ce
match et on aura donc TR
armes
ça va être super Fab
ouais on aurait pu espér je pense même
pas pouroi il joue en fait bah oui
abandonne là Fabi all est
blanc il écrit son son truc il est très
heureux quoi
ah
oui donc ça en fait ça sert à rien c'est
que dans la première ronde gagné donc il
mène à zé et il va pas perdre ça avec
les noir
donc G qui fasse nul en
fait est-ce que ça peut changer pour un
départage à la fin peut-être
je sais
pas la Kay au nombre de victoire
peut-être s'il donne un truc je sais pas
moi non je crois
pas
ouis c'est bizarre on regarde un truc
qui sert à rien
rien ta tête ça te bute en fait ça me
bute
ou c'est l'équivalent d'un truc de coupe
desvis quand il a déjà 30-0
quoi tu peux jouer tu peux ne pas jouer
quoi
mais fait ton t des 4 il pète les coups
quoi c'est bien quoi je chens qu'il joue
pour gagner hein is je sais mais ça rend
fou hein ilbe
quoi il va gagner
d'ailleurs a
priori deux faiblesses unu de cas je
sais pas j'ai pas regardé exactement
la ça joue que ah c'est ro
f32 de
qualité
ah il va prendre
kayas bravo victoire 2-0 et donc ce sera
le seul match qui n'ira pas à l'armagéon
on se retrouve dans je sais pas après la
pause quoi n'hésitez pas à aller sur la
chaîne officielle un chess pour
poursivre et voir un petit peu
les les enchères cachées à tout de suite
les amis saviez-vous que vous pouvez
pimenter vos parties en ligne et vous
analyser avec des mojis il vous suffit
de cliquer sur l'icône emoji puis de
sélectionner votre emoji et de cliquer
avec le bouton gauche de la souris sur
les chiquers vous pouvez choisir parmi
une multitude de notations de coup
d'animation d'moticone et même vos
personnalités préférées du monde des
échecs les émoticones et les emmojis
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coup et les animations spéciales restent
sur les chiquier jusqu'à ce qu'elles soi
effacé pour ce faire il suffit de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur l'emmoji ou de cliquer sur le
bouton tout effacé
essayez-les tous et amusez-vous bien sur
[Musique]
com
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'était c'était vraiment amusant parce
que Magnus a pris 15 minutes pour l'ARM
magadon ouais il voulait vraiment les
blancs pour être vraiment bien
sûr et et ikarou lui a pris 940 et du
coup Magnus regrettait de pas avoir pris
939 donc on a pas trop compris du coup
pourquoi tu prends pas 99
alors débile mais ouais bon je pense
que j'arrive pas trop à comprendre en
fait les joueurs
parfois en fait j'arrive pas à
comprendre si sont full troll parce
qu'ils prennent le truc un peu comme un
la jambe la jambe d're côté il a quand
même tellement de fric en jeu que ben
ouais finalement c'est dessous la jambe
quoi j'arrive pas trop à comprendre la
mentalité des joueurs en
fait enfin quoi qu'il en
soit
les blanc en tout cas avec ses 15
minutes Ikar AA
940 et obligation de gagner pour Magnus
t le même truc avec C arm
guon Magnus il va vouloir juste avoir
une position qui joue vivante
ou
l'inverseon sèche qui joue pas
voilà c'est log vite
nul
mais mais du coup ouais je m'attends une
sorte de catalan ou de
d'anglaise pour
Magnus c'est pere dit quand même que si
av jou D4 D5 C4 C5 c'est qu'il avit pas
grand chose sur
d4ou éviter la
Catalane qu' reviennent pas pour le
moment fa c'est encore la pause ouais je
pensais que allit revenir plus vite moi
ant de bien se reposer pour être au top
pour C Armagedon
vous pouvez voir bien s sur la
chaîne
anglaisz petites enchères ou quoi voir
maximebi temp il prend
W en fait ils sont en train de de
montrer un peu les autres enchères
qu'ils sont très heureux du tableau
c'est une excellente idée ils ont bien
raison
c'est vraiment hyper intéressant à
voir ça per après d'en rediscuter un peu
aussi en
plateau et Maxime qui lui aussi encore
les blancs on n pas les temps
encore
9 minutes Maxime 24 secondes il a pris
les
Noirs mais du coup je crois
hein
du coup je crois
ouais je crois ouais Maxime elle est
noir
plutôt bon choix je
pense de sa
part
et ça va repartir ah voilà c'est les
joueurs sont là je vois sur les
caméras
Magus qui s'hydrate
bien
ça met du temps hein à commencer
ouais je sais pas
wouah pour a bien le temps de se
concentrer
ouais tu as raison ça si ça permet
d'augmenter la qualité de jeu c'est tant
mieux désolé non mais je pense ça l'idée
mais après là j'ai l's sont bien
concentrés qu même eu ils aimeraient que
ça
commenceou il a l'air d'être un peu de
chercher l'arbitre du
regard toujours faire passer la
cameraman qualité de jeu en premier
est-ce qu'on a déjà essayé les les les
les armagadon en partie
longue avec en cher ouais mais fait 4
bizarre
ptroped a pu penser qu' voulais garder
les blancs
pour
Conner mais je sais que c'est pas si con
non c'est un peu con mais pas
oua donc en fait ikarou il a décidé de
jouer viment il fait des TR et pas de
c'est
beau il connait
pas
bizarre
je sais
pas retourne pas dans une P ouis mais
c'est les
blers mais temp d'avance parce que tuas
les
blanc chelou
quoi
mais bizarre que Magnus connaisse pas la
réf de ces trucs bah il joue enin ça pe
l' idos ce qu'il a joué mais peut-être
qu'en fait il y a pas de reféfute
c'estant c'estêre jouable en fait pour
de vrai je sais que c'est pas si débile
hein
il est quand même mieux ave que les
Blancs par qu'en gros il a ce cavalier
en
E5 par rapport au cavalier en
F6 et il est arrivé donc à jouer fou F4
donc développer ce F dame alors que les
noir F C8 tu as plus de mal quoi tu peux
pas aller en F5 tu peux pas aller en G4
euh tu peux tu pour un jour
d'ailleurs tour 8 ouais tour 20
ou qu' un reféfute non mais moi aussi je
connaissais la reféfute mais je crois
qu'en fait c'est loin d'être si simple
ah oui non mais dame 2 c'est pas c'est
pas fini hein l'autre fait dame 7 tu
prends le 4 il fait D6 tu fais des4
prend après joue pour grand rock je CIS
que même tout le truc de refut c'est
toujours pas si simple à la fin
[Musique]
mais bon normal ça pas quand même une
grande réputation pour les Noirs
quoi un
jouet C5
fut vraiment une péop inversée quoi
ouais ses ouvertures semiouteuse on va
dire peut-être jouable mais bien réussi
en tout cas pas débile
soit le D4 D5 C4 C5 ou en fait il essayé
de faire de la symétrie P3 je te copie
aussi et ça dû le faire marrer il a dû
faire tourner un peu les
[Musique]
turbines a joué hier contre je pense pas
surpris ouais mais
bonok l' fait une foisit une fois si tu
regardes tout ce que tout le monde fait
une
fois ait une fois justement il va pas
refaire quoi h
ou alors tu regardes en
[Musique]
rapidos car a moins de temps parce que
c'est l'armagadon les Noirs ont moins de
temps mais ils sont obligés de les blans
do gag BL doivent gagner
ouais
en tout cas Magnus qui est en train de
rattraperar à la pendule
ouais mais c'est pas la
partie comment
dire
du coup ton avantage à la pendu
effectivement fond comme neige au soleil
et euh position ben éorme pas fait
d'imprécision pendant ce temps doncas
plus d'avantage ni à la ni à la position
c'est chiant de devoir absolument gagner
quoi hyper
pénible
en tout cas j'aime beaucoup ce ce
système de match fable ces allers retour
avec Armagedon je trouve que ça apporte
vraiment un plus ça reste quand même
assez dynamique le
tournoi j'aime bien c'est mieux que ce
qu'il faisait avant avec les matchs en
quatre parties là tu as deux parties il
y a pas de match nul donc tu as
forcément même un partout ça joue encore
tu as forcément un vainqueur à la fin et
finalement c'est relativement rapide
puisque tu vois un match va durer à peu
près 2h 2h é
quart 2h 2h et/4 on va dire ça et ça
reste quand même relativement dynamique
tu arrivrive quand même à faire un
tournoi assez sérieux en en à peine 8
jours donc c'est bien
ok
c'est3 ve monas peut-être des cavaliers
B5
oui
sur C prend D4 il compte justement aller
faire c
B5 pour soit prendre des 4 soit surtout
peut-être prendre le fou le fou des6
bien sûr aller le croquer ce fou
Fab allez le
croquet non mais qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous dans le chat de format
trouis pas que c'est un peu un peu cool
un peu novateur un peu
dynamique ça nous fait des beaux des
retours des beaux matchs ouais des on
attendant vos retour retour aussi
toujours intéressant mais ça fait ça
fait des beaux matchs et ça reste quand
même relativement rapide là voilà on a
deux matchs ça c'est fait en 5h c'est
c'est finiôt quoi ça change des parties
longues tu as qu'une partie en 5h là tu
as quelque part mat de matchs
des matchs de plusieurs
parties qu'on peut avoir beaucoup
d'échecs et les gens sont mis dans de
bonnes conditions ils ont bien le temps
quand même de de souffler de déployer
leur leur jeu quoi ah mais c'est vrai
que c'est
important
kou qui enfin réfléchit en tout
cas il voit ce qu' les B5 arrivé alors
il se questionner estce que je fais à 6
mais bon c'est quand des perd de temps
tout ça C4 c'est prend
des4 et il part sur
C4
F de FO
F3 tu vois du coup les les gens sont
quand même assez d'accord avec moi dans
le chat tu on voit du j piano quique le
format est idéal non mais c'est vrai que
c'est un très beau très beau format il y
a pas mal de suspense et ça avance ça
avance gentiment eu plusieurs saisons de
C champion ch tour mais ça ça a été
amélioré là on voit qu'ils arrivent un
peu à tirer la quintessence
maintenant vraent nous
offrir cette apothéose dernier tournoi
de de la saison quoi ouais ouais c'est
sûr
ouais ça ça fait vivant et quand même un
bon niveau et il se passe il se passe
des
choses d des
deux
ouais il il a quand même 4 minutes
d'avance il y a pas de il y a plus que
que plus une seconde à partir du 60e
donc il a une vraie une vraie DIF au
temp
là encore du mal à
seitu après toujours le débat agedon
comme je le disais mort
subite du coup ça enlèvera du dynamisme
mort subite ouais parce que le problème
du mort subite c'est quoi 15 + 3 mort
subite en fait il peut tu peux y avoir
ça peut durer des
heures sub faut que so
partiesit donc c'est ce serait dommage
ça un peu la la cadence du du
truc
Maxim qui serait perdant est-ce que tu
peux check ça Fab euh allez je vais
checker faut chat ou
ouais ouais check ça serait vraiment la
très très mavaise opération Maxime VO
ser ouais surtout qu'il était bien
surtout si kugay en plus par que écoute
perdant c'est un grand mot mais oui il
su quoi il a 4 minutes de retard il se
fait attaquer fait défoncer en fait
ouais mais saut qu' a les blanc hein
contre contre lireza lza qui lu faire
une encher très basse pour pour avoir
les Noirs mais c'est pas bête contre
contre sa c'est pas bête ouais mais
après so il peut
être toujours pareil hein là j'ai
l'impression que Magnus il commence un
peu à le travailler au corps là qui des
TR ça a l'air fort des petits coups dans
le fois ouais
maisok est
bien de plus
je dit ce saut il est étonnant il est
fort
prise C3 prise C3
ok il veut vite se débarrasser de la
perte fou adverse en jouant donc ce coup
de fou G4 mais du coup
bon il y a un petit petit truc pour les
blancs quand même j'ai l'impression
meilleure
structure S êreichon c'est un petit truc
mais c'est c'est petit quand même ouais
resa foutu
ou il est pas bien attends je vais je
vais aller voir pour nous parce que moi
j'ai pas le délai enfin les gens vont
recevoir notre truc dans une minute mais
oui firou est vraiment complètement
perdant je peux vous le dire c'est
finito et Maxime c'est finito aussi
ouais ouais donc en fait c'est genre
hyper mauvais si carou gag parce que le
truc c'est que Magnus les Français le
rattraperont pas non et si en plusarou
il est déjà devant sil remarque encore
un
irattrapable
irrattrapable point mais il
enoreav faut essayer pas finir dernier
avantnier de ce tour quand même sinon
c'est irrévible c'est
l'élimination mais bon Magnus Mme essay
de monter sa dame de faire C4 de CR
passé voir
pas dit son dernier
mot estce Plô pourra jouer les noirs ou
les blancs pour l'armagadon je sais pas
moi j'ai jamais réfléchi à cette cadence
avec 15 minutes en armagadon mais en
blitz dans les armagadons classique moi
j'essis toujours de prendre les blancs
même si je sais que normalement c'est
mieux les Noirs mais moi jeurais plutôt
pour avoir les blancs
ouais je sais pas ouais dur ça dépend
aussi de l'adversaire finalement la
dynamique du match ouais ça dépend dein
chos
là en fait je sais pas avec cette
cadence rapide j'ai l'impression que
c'est mieux d'avoir les noirmes ouais
peut-être ouais gen en 9 minutes tu as
le de fin partie correcte il que 6
minutes mais tu vas pas te faire tomber
comme ça enfin 5 mais moi en fait
j'étais pour l'arme à gueddon pas de
rajou tu te fais flaguer comme une merde
à la fin c'est la VI
ah ouais je trve aussi ou préféré mais
de base c'était je crois prévu pour être
avec plus 2 à partir du 60e et je crois
que c'est les joueurs qui ont changé et
demander que ce soit que plus 1 h je
pense les joueurs aussi hein
bah il faut que ça a un prix quoi quand
même de si tu as moins de temps c'est
parce qu'on peut te faire
tomber mais comme tu peux faire nul tu
compenses et et voilà mais si en fait on
donne tous les avantages que en plus tu
vas pas tomber et que tu as un rajout
temps et compagnie c'est vra que plus un
seulement c'est pas énorme tu remontes
pas vraent temps plus 2 oui mais c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont mis plus 1 B c'est
les joueurs qui ont demandé à j'ai
compris à l'unanimité dans le players
meeting en fait il y a des règles qui
ont été
changé mais je suis d'accord avec toi
que je préfère même plus zé et puis que
ce soit un peu ça l'arme à gedon c'est
un peu ça aussi mais c'était ouais
traditionnellement ça a été fait pour ça
quoi
après moi je préfère le mort subite àarm
magedon mais bon après ça c'est des
préférences
personnelles je trouve que mort subite
déjà c'est marrant ça peut faire des
ouais tu tu sais pas quand ça se fini
quoi ouais et puis euh je trouve ça joue
comme ça joue je sais pas comment
dire je v pas te mettre tu vas pas faire
tu plus ouais ma tu obligé de jouer aux
échecs en fait ou tu gardes la nature du
jeu mais comme je dis après voilà il y a
beaucoup beaucoup cet argument moi jeai
je l'ai souvent entendu vraiment de dire
ouais mais ça peut être infini parce
qu'il peut y avoir des Nules de manière
infinie donc oui là mais l'argument est
complètement valide
hein com on disa tout à l'heure i il est
valide théoriquement parlant mais oui
non il est complètement cette partie
déjà peut être infini en elle-même enfin
oui tout peut être infini c'est valide
l'argument est valide il est débile mais
il est
valide l'un n'est pas n'empêche pas
l'autre
oui c'est un argument c'est absolument
stupide mais mais c'est un vrai
argument mais
euh moi je je préfère plus ça en en OTB
ça permet de bouger la pièce ouais tu
peux en 0,5 tu peux jouer un coup sur
éique tu veux jouer plusieurs coup en
une seconde
[Musique]
hein a pas aimé je pense que vou faire
qu' prend C3 laisser cavalio cette
fourchette prendre C V tour C8 C C3 bien
placé mais il a voulu renforcer la
structure comme ça Wesley qui a battu
regarde bon ben Westley
bravo il nous a fait mal aujourd'hui
Westley ouais la le match contre Maxime
on peut on peut vraiment tant quoi
nourrir quelques
regrets Maxime perd contre la zavic là
ce serait
vraiment bon écoute il s'accroche mais
bon il moins bien mais qui était de
moins mais il arrivve à mettre un peu
des Barb et il s'est pas fait matter
quoi peut suivre la fin de Maxime quand
même il plus qu'une minuteandême pas
beau sa position il s'est refait
attaquer par rapport à la position que
j'avais sous les
yeux compris que c'était pas nakamur
firouja
je pense qu'on reconnaît tous Maxime
avec les
Noirs j'espère en tout
cas cas c'est quoi c'est une qualité
matériement
parlant G2 qui fragile G5 fragile le roi
fragile
gaffe de la mais sûement il y a quelques
coups maxime a du contregaffer en tout
cas je pense c'est une partie très
importante pour
Maxime que si tu perds là ce sera enfin
tu es encore favori hein pour faire tap
6 attention mais tu as plus trop le
droit à l'erreur de rien et c'est
chaudin c'est un peu comme ciné en Ligue
2 cette année c'est que quand tu es au
milieu du match contre sa tu on joue top
là tout d'un coup tu dis ouais bon ben
là du
coup tranquille bon tant pis
et et là si tu perds ce ce match là tu
commences vraiment à dire que tu tu
joues place 58 en fait surtout tu donnes
finalement un point un adversaire direct
même si on croit pas trop en
laav ok ça l'air d'être plutôt bien là
ce qu'a fait
Maxime de peutêtre
is mon le pion avancer
c'est tu faire
ouais ça a l'air
dur do avoir le Maxime si per contre
laavic
dame B4 do être safe s veut pas se
prendre la tête mais sinon dame b4ant
mais fou mais je je pense qu'il a envie
de faire un truc comme
ça H4 cou il f des4 gen oui F des c'est
s
F5 on sait jamais foutu mesam 5 5 F pr
F3 il fait F 4 faut tenter de ah il
tente pas FPR
F3 après ça devait pas marcher
hein en fait il a pas beaucoup d'échec
je
crois quand le G3
c'est encore tu G6 peut-être tu as pas
l'air d'être bien ouais mais il va
monter il va mettre la dame au milieu un
moment ouais en plus il a des contre
échecs peut-être à certains moments ça
sent très mauvais pour pour Maxime il 11
qui joue en 40 secondes ça devrait y
arriver mais le problème c'est que
est-ce qu'il sera encore en vie dans la
position à ce
moment-là 7 bien joué va attaquer
drit prend F3 il tente
tente ro F2 comme hyper fort pas con F2
F2 pas con
ro ouais ça doit gagner mais mais tu
peux r 3 R3 il y a pas d'échec ouais B
vite r La Tour est protégée
ouais ça va être abandon je crois
difficile pour
Maxime mais surtout qu'il en reste des
coup à jouer là mais après il pourrait
les jouer les 20 cou je pensais queav
allit perdre tous ses matchs moi donc
surprise et elle
tombe au pire des moments pour
nousureusement pour nous contre Maxime
euh une seule bonne nouvelle peut-être
le seul c'est que r rayon de
soleil alors c'est quoi la pendule de
Magnus 2 minutes contre 54 secondes a
plus de temps quoi
ouais et Magnus en plus il lu accéléré
la
tronche ça veut dire que Magnus et
Wesley tout perdre et déjà re limite il
tout per j'exagère mais je veux
dire a un des deux qui va jouer contre
l'autre donc qui gagnera un match et
celui qui gagnera ce match là ce sera
déjà
fini gu journée he pour les Français qui
ont perdu quatre matchs sur
quat il jou contre qui r le match
d'avant Maxim a perdu contre so ça ouais
Maxim
so cont contrearo on av vu la fin de la
partie là qui était chaude et puis il a
perdu
2-0 mais ikarou ai va se retrouver dans
le dur il a qu'une victoire ça va se
jouer entre ikarou
nardor il va avoir de victoires là ouais
mais bon un peu moins un peu en dessous
quand même
quoi mais ouais on peut avoir un
français au moins
éliminé de ça paraît quand même peu gros
mais ouais c'est
[Musique]
possible
surtout que Maxime il reste quand Mme
Magnus à jouer ala aussi je crois il
vont se jouer entre eux l'ffrontement
ouais et après il y aura l'affrontement
entre les Français ouais qui permettra
peut-être à l'un des deux d'arriver
simplement en
barrage carou qui
su luchanger les dames puis fut F4 fou
G5 ou
euh je pense sil peut mais après il peut
échanger fut F4 ouais F4
G5
PSer sur no pas mal tout ça
[Musique]
h il qui est
passé tu peux pas
échanger va tenter Cali quand
même
le F2 j'ai pas mis la bonne bon persav
les joueurs on les voyait
pas je CIS qu' fait juste tomber en
fait c'est choses fait donc
Magnus qui s'impose
jeterors est-ce qu'il ont été mis à jour
oui ont été mis à jour Magnus et wesle
victoir en 4 match ana ils ont deux et
puis a beaucoup de joueurs à un point
dont malheureusement nos deux Français
et euh comment on disait va falloir
euh peut-être faire deux sur TR
euh un sur tris peut peut-être suffire
mais
ouais façon ils joueront ensemble donc
un des deux marquera un point ouais et
il faudra gagner d'autres matchs à côté
on va espérer quand même qu'il fasse au
moins 5 si la zavi quand même censé être
en dessous hein donc euh on espère quand
même qui qui mettent les points mais bon
il reste aussi du laavic dans le Range
des des autres joueurs en adversaire
donc euh on espérra que ça se passe
mieux demain et c'est avec plaisir qu'on
vous retrouvera demain à 18h mesdames et
messieurs pass c'est une bonne soirée